welcome everybody welcome to West area
plumbing MoneySmart cargo and I'm
chairing the meeting this evening just
first housekeeping there are no fire
alarm scheduled this evening that are
aware also if you do hear an alarm
please make your way out of the building
in an orderly fashion and meet and car
park by the side of the windmill public
please note this is a planning meeting
with public participation not a public
meeting therefore only persons registers
to speak will be allowed to do so during
the course of the evening this meetings
being webcast so if you don't want to be
shown on them in the big worldwide world
then please let naksan at the
appropriate time for our speakers this
evening some tips on using microphones
you get to close
it becomes distorted so if you just an a
little wave right from it and speak
clearly you'll be all right I'm sure the
sequence events for each application is
as follows I will introduce the offered
the item supported by the case officer
who offers a description town and parish
counselors will be allowed to speak for
three minutes members of the public
objecting will be allowed to speak for
2-3 minutes the applicant will then be
allowed to speak for a commercial at
time either three or six minutes I will
give a 30-second warning before times up
ward members are then allowed to speak
for up to five minutes at all stages the
members of the committee are allowed to
ask questions following the presentation
then the members will be able to
question the case officer on any
technical issues that have arisen during
the process or that they've identified
through the report and then we move into
debate and the vote all this is detailed
in the agenda
can I ask please that you'll turn your
phone's off your mobile phones off or -
Simon - please thank you there is an
update sheets distributed around showing
any late-breaking items so you can have
a look at those and now I'm gonna ask
the officers to introduce themselves
starting from my writing Caroline mash
committee administrator Raj chambers
legal services
is grim law I'm a planning team leader
my role is as an impartial adviser to
the committee and to help answer any
questions that arise I'm bound by the
code of Professional Conduct of the
Royal time planning Institute during the
meeting I may be asked to comment on
point raised or seek clarifications and
advise on planning practice to ensure
that the decision made by the committee
is best placed to withstand any
challenge committee members are not
bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice from us
my name's Anthony and I'm a senior
planning officer John Gardner assistant
planner
James Hodgkins planner Charlotte Dix
planning officer thank you everybody
all right apologies for absence the
first I'd like to say is councillor
Giles called me this afternoon saying
that she's unable to country to get a
hospital for him council fielding is
substituting but also counts of ordering
councillor pain thank you
right disclosures of interest members if
there are any items on the agenda this
evening then you have an interest in
would you please declare it to cancer
Bridget like a chair application 1701
736 ful I received an email staff name
with some pictures on I believe they're
going to be shown later on and that ice
cream will also apply to all the members
of the committee thank you yes I think
that has been distributed widely yeah I
don't know the id3 application 1703 3
which is Marlborough works
I'm the adjoining war member I've made
some comments but I've seen nothing
since I made those comments which which
has counteracted them so I think I'd be
judged to have a negative views
okay so I will be sitting out ok counsel
Thank You captain I've got three
applications in my ward I should be
speaking as one member thank you very
much
I have seen that those emails been sent
around you really are comment on that in
a moment
just a point procedure unfortunately
there's been an administrative error the
last item on the agenda should have come
to the fore it would be the first one
I've decided that I'm happy to take that
so we're bringing the the item for 17 /
0 1 7 36 / full sunny fields to the
first item then we'll be moving into the
agenda as it is shown minutes of meeting
none
okay in that case then we'll move into
the first item which is 7 things - oh
one 7 36 / full Sun details
Oh to Antony thank you chair members
this is there an application for a
two-story side extension with a loft
conversion and remodel a new principal
elevation just remind members that the
application was originally presented at
a Planning Committee on the 27th to
September 2017 and was determined in
line with the officer recommendation for
refusal a decision was however made on
the 28th - September 2017 to return the
application to Planning Committee due to
an officer oversight - it meant that the
applicants PowerPoint presentation was
not shown in full during his opportunity
to speak which will be rectified this
evening here we have the site on
Ludington Road as black dots as usual
and moving on and there's the red line
it's a Welling sitting amongst a ribbon
development on the southern side of the
road it's just to show members the the
building on a arrow photograph and here
we have the block plan front of the
dwelling is here and we see the
neighboring properties either side
in existing elevations modest cottage
and proposed elevations some members
will be familiar with this from the last
time and here's an artist's impression
of the proposal and in context some
Street photographs the dwelling
dwellings either side as the dwelling to
the left as you look at the front of the
property that's the dwelling to the
right a bit more of a distant view and
just remembers information a side
extension was approved in August 2015 on
the left-hand side of the property
remembers the recommendation is to
refuse as previously thank you chair I
think you just on the as regards the
presentation by the applicant I believe
a second set was sent through however
that shows in photo montage which is
against policy not to show that
particularly that's correct chair and
could I just add that we had to two
additional letters of support to the
application which aren't included on the
update sheet so this is a verbal update
and the these supporting comments are
summarized as follows many different
types of properties are situated a
long-running Ludington Road the
improvements to the property would be
significant and improve the overall
appearance of the current site and the
proposed application is considered in
keeping with the surrounding properties
Thank You chair thank you our first
speaker this evening then is caps are
John Warrender from buddington parish
council
yep yes
Council balance I'm sure will show you
where to what to do could you cancel
violence would you show thank you
what comes next
okay right counsel you have three
minutes in your own time thank you very
much thank you my name is dawuan de
locas and parish council just like to
say that we have supported this
application from the beginning we think
that the street scene will be much
improved by this proposal also if you
take a journey up Ludington road there's
a lot of different types of housing
along Reddington Road ranging from the
1940s nineteen sixties up to the present
day as you go past the racecourse
entrance in Ludington Road
there are several properties basically
replaced in 2016 that are very similar
to this sort of style and also if you go
further up and take a left down Avon
Bank Drive there are other properties in
a very similar style it seems to be a
trend to add these sort of glass fascias
to the front of properties balconies
those sort of things and we're not
adverse to accept in those in Ludington
because there are a lot of diverse
properties along the road currently in
the in the front you can see there's
sort of containers in the in the front
garden and local residents have
commented on this sort of saying to us
what's going on with this can it not be
sorted out I think that the visual
drawing that has been presented looks
very nice we don't think as approach
council that there's anything in this
application that goes against the core
strategy the actual footprint of the
building is not dissimilar
to the original even if you take the
front fascia up to the level of the
chimney of the old building it's very
similar it does seem to us that there's
some sort of dislike to the overall
design but we're not quite sure what
that is and we're not quite sure that
it's relevant if you look along the road
even just going into the to the old
village of Ludington there's some very
modern styles on the left and the right
of Ludington road and we basically think
that this proposal would fit in very
well within the neighborhood and these
beliefs okay all right okay and we think
that overall it will enhance the street
scene of Ludington Road especially to
get rid of the containers which
obviously residents have commented on
and we hope that they're superseded
plans that you can see here will be
favorably looked at tonight thank you
thank you cancer any questions okay
thank you very much thank you our next
speaker is Daniel Payne the applicant
mr. Payne you have three minutes when
you're ready if you could just bear with
me mr. Payne I'll get your presentation
up
would you just like me to run it or
should I stop it tell me when you
started okay
so what we're starting now good evening
early last year I consulted neighbors
and parish council with my plans and
received full support from them I urge
the committee to endorse that this is a
sustainable development of the 71 year
old house to create a modern home for my
family over the past few months have
actively attempted to negotiate with the
planning officer in order to find a
compromise and move on with the
renovation this is a first this is this
is its first redevelopment many houses
on Ludington Road were bungalows and
over the last 20 years almost all of
them have been redeveloped so Ludington
Road is now in the collective mix of
houses with different styles and various
architecture indeed both the neighboring
properties were bungalows until recently
to quote Molly Giles the last night the
party should not be penalized I have
lived in the house houses for several
years in order to understand what would
work best when it comes to renovating
and to really understand what fits in
with the street scene the idea has
always been not to knock down the house
add to the landfill problems but to use
the existing in an ingenious way and
combine ideas or drag this house into
the 21st century whilst being respectful
for neighbors this development is
proportional to plot as you can see the
house only occupies a small proportion
of the plot it respects enabling this
there are no windows overlooking on the
side windows the window sills are set at
2 meters so that nobody can overlook the
development has several eco-friendly
features I'm using solar panels ground
source heat from solar heat electric car
charging rainwater harvesting this house
is basically being toward a passive
house not quite there 95% now let's
address the objections were raised the
planning when the planning is submitted
the existing front porch projection is
800 mil the top balcony is 300 the lower
balcony is 1200 inline with the gas
therefore there is no forward projection
the other point well as that house is
overlooking countryside the house is
overlooking private farm and a true
surgeon's large yard la a landscape
business Borden Hill nursery greenhouses
he doesn't have a footpath and my
alleged low hedge over the size of two
meters tall
the last objection I'd like to address
as the house has a bulky design when it
comes down to the design and
architecture it boils down to personal
taste and the point of the planning
application I believe is to ensure that
any development the respect the planning
rules in place the balconies in the loft
area of 30 seconds please an efficient
modern design and ties in with a more
modern or extension the ridge also
similarly will perfectly fit with the
neighbors properties
I've now presented the features and
objections if you have any questions I
urge you to ask them before dismissing
thank you very much never sell any
questions you would like to ask thank
you for that and he just explained to me
what the materials are they're gonna be
used as he would in their from what I
understand this is a remodeling so it's
gonna be the base of the house now but
with presumably render or something I'm
surrender to an over layer of insulation
then take render so it's a pink the SAP
value of the property increasing his
performance getting it towards a passive
house the reuse of the roof tiles is not
correctly illustrated in the first
pictures that are on the plan they've
red tiles that you saw very briefly in
the in the screenshot is what is going
to be used at the front so it's
retaining that red tile feature with a
little bit of timber introduced to keep
it sharp the whole idea is to make it
sharp clean okay thank you very much
right counsel bonds oh good evening this
earth has been to us before you know it
was it the refusal then you couldn't put
the picture of the old house there if
you liked if you want a picture and
basically yep it was three three and the
Chairman does the casting boat there's a
lot of properties like this properties
in looking to no no no there's a lot of
properties like this all these houses
were built after caravans up to the war
there was one Caravan left on the night
airfield and as you can see this is now
got old and not in keeping with the with
the surroundings you saw more about the
hazards and I did in the respect of just
going to look at it but as far as I'm
concerned there were quite a number of
properties very similar to this there is
more support the first council is
supporting it going back to Ludington
road one three one came here and we
refuse that application because the
windows were looking out on the
neighbors and that meant to appeal we
won the appeal and the inspector said
that this was an urban road in a rural
setting with a big hill on one side and
a river on the other as far as I'm
concerned I'm happy to support this and
I think it will be a major improvement
on that side okay Thank You counsel
any questions thank you thank you all
right let's move to technical questions
Cal security just go through the reasons
for refusal here we've got on page one
two three
oh yes alterations and modifications
including extensions will be of an
appropriate scale and subservient
relation to the existing building that
seems to be one of the problems what
what where's the problem with that that
where's the extension going to be as
we're looking at at it is on the left of
the ride to live it's on the left that
seemed to me to be subservient
I think it's acknowledged in the report
that's okay that's okay
oh it okay right so it's merely the de
style and how that affects the house
itself and the houses around it that's
the gist of it okay any other questions
or technical nature no okay I shall open
to a debate council coach I think I
probably said something similar last
time and my view hasn't changed that if
it's a seems to be a widely supported
design and and I think it's a nice
design I don't think I don't think um I
don't think these materials are
inappropriate on the Ludington road as
the Parish Council said there are other
examples of modern design and they look
good the house at the moment is is very
boring and very old and it does look
like it needs work and and a more
traditional sort of little side
extension keeping the same brickwork in
the same style I think this looks better
and if it's a question of what it looks
like which it seems to be then then I'm
very happy to support this and and I
don't think it goes again I think it's
just a different interpretation of of
cs9 cancer
Thank You chair yes having looked at
this again with the benefit of a
PowerPoint presentation and it does look
that there is a fairly eclectic mix of a
fairly modern houses here and only in
fact some sort of you know monk Georgian
looking it what I don't particularly
like this this this design and I would
certainly prefer to see the retention of
the of the current roofline just looking
at it I tend to agree with counsel a
carriage that it's not going to be out
of keeping with other properties on the
Ludington Road so on that case if that
was a proposal I'll be happy to second
that we grant this consent moment
council fielding I think from memory I
voted against this one because I felt it
was just a bit too much but as the
parish council are coming forward with
it again and saying they support it it
does make the rather old Tod building
look very much jazzed up and I'm
prepared to support it it's an
interesting one isn't it because
obviously beauty is in the eye of the
beholder I have no objection to modern
buildings and then in the game in the
location I feel that this would be quite
acceptable I just have my real concerns
about it in this particular road and
this is obviously a personal view I'm
looking though because of that I won't
I won't use my personal views on this I
would have to look at the actual
policies that we have before us and the
reason to refuse are fairly fairly
explicit there again cs9 and cs20 now
cf9 however does allow for exceptions in
design for innovation and this is one of
the things we could if we wished to
apply to this particular scheme as long
as we still say that it will not be
against policy we are actually applying
to policy but in an interpretive manner
thanks chair I think that this all boils
down to the an individual's view over
the design and architectural merit it's
very subjective as the Parish Council
have pointed out from a personal
perspective quite don't like that I
don't think it's in keeping with the
street scene
further down the Lighting's and wrote in
to the Lud's answer in itself yes there
are other examples of modern design but
when you look at this particular area
particularly two buildings either side I
don't think it is in keeping and
actually I think the officers
recommendation is sound and so I am
airing on the wrists on the side of
refusing along with us with the office
of recommendation I do however
appreciate and understand reasoning to
the contrary in this instance I am going
to put proposal that we refused in line
with offers recommendation thank you we
have a proposal I will second that
proposal for refusal of members the vote
before you is to refuse plan permission
for 17-0 173 6/4 all those in favor
against 2 against 3 the motion fails do
I have a propose a counter carriage yeah
I propose that we do go against the the
officers in this particular case just on
a matter of interpretation of cas9 I
think it's I think you're perfectly
valid Peter to say that it's a valid
conclusion to make one way or the other
on this one and I think after listening
to the to the parish council and reading
cs9 on you know how things the first the
first few words are all forms of
development would improve the quality of
the public realm and I think this does
from where we are and the other things
about what's in the local area are also
relevant so on a different
interpretation of cs9 I propose we grant
and are you I did mention about cf
design innovation is that something you
wish to bring into this no I don't see
that particularly right driver seconder
for that I'm happy to ii did thank you
right members the vote before you is to
grant a confirmation of 1701 736 such
thought all those in favor chair can I
just mention conditions sorry I
apologize it's very straightforward I
think I would just suggest that the
standard time limit condition the
application to be constructed in
accordance with the plans and submission
of materials I'm sure right thank you
for that right the boat before you is to
grant a plane Commission of 7500 173 6/4
all those in favor 3 chairman against
abstentions one abstention
thank you this committee therefore
resolves to grant plan for efficient
Commission for 17 such oh one 736 slash
fall thank you the next item on the
agenda is 75032 below three sash belt
which is the more Burrell works new road
Studley the presenting officer is Alice
and over to you when you're ready
Thank You Shannon the application site
which denoted by the black dot in the
center of the plan is located within the
built-up area steadily the application
relates to a commercial site in the
center of steadly currently accessed off
new Road it comprises a business unit
constructed an a mix of brick and
corrugated steel with associated
hard-surfaced areas a public footpath
lines the southern and western
boundaries of the site and two groups of
trees protected by tree preservation
orders are located within the site and
denoted by the green - lined on the plan
this is a hybrid application for
planning permission is sought on the
western part of the site for the
erection of 65 bird care home falling
within use Class C - our outline
Planning Commission is sort on the
eastern part of the site for the
erection of up to ten dwellings the
existing building on site would be
demolished this plan shows the detailed
proposals for the care home which
includes a new vehicle er access from
Poole Road and areas for gardens and car
parking it also shows the indicative
layout for ten dwellings accessed from
new road this slide shows the east and
north elevations of the proposed care
home it would range from two storeys to
two and a half stories and would be
constructed in a mix of brick render and
timber cladding the south and west
elevations can be seen on this slide the
applicant has provided this
visualization of the proposed care home
and indicative housing to give members
of feel for how it could look this photo
is taken from new road and shows the
site with the existing commercial
building in situ in the context of the
existing site access this photo was
taken further down new road with the
existing site access indicated the
scientists visible from the public
footpath with which wraps around the
southern and western boundaries here we
are stood on a public footpath toward
the southeast corner of the site and
again on the public footpath toward the
southwest corner of the site here we are
stood on Poole Road with the site behind
the hedgerow which can be seen and taken
further down the same Road
to the existing commercial building is
visible beyond the boundary hetero
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to
conditions and financial contribution as
detailed within the committee report
thank you thank you guys all right our
first speakers can't support even from
study protocol Thank You chair members
the committee we have a very valuable
plot of land in the mr. Bligh
the the parish has decided would be very
appropriate for Hazen there is as you're
aware a real shortage of building
language understood instantly this was
designated within ere parish plan as a
site that we would accept housing on
what we've got is something that really
doesn't actually meet that need we have
a care home that has been built that
we've got no identified need for and
we're not even aware that there is
somebody that will operate it we have
houses that we the still an outline plan
we've got no guarantee they'll be
delivered what what we could have is a
site like the co-op site that gets
flattened because developer gets greedy
and then it's left for 10 years or
something is sorted out we would like to
see a application for the whole site and
we would prefer to see this developed as
housing for the whole of the site in the
middle of the village and provides
social housing develop again very
careful ten houses no social housing
which is not appropriate in this
location the other point that we think
quite strongly about and we actually
dealt with the on two occasions on this
is the footpath that runs on the site it
causes a fair few problems around the
village with antisocial behavior litter
loitering damage we would love to see
that footpath come through the center of
this society and actually be included in
the site and the site
taken right up to the perimeter so that
the haze is that back onto it improve
their security and the security the
building itself is improved by leading
the footpath there it would create
further problems and we don't think that
it's appropriate then you're the one is
the windows in the building are
overlooking the children's playground
and the children's playing field which
we also think is inappropriate be much
better to see Harris in there and
therefore we think the committee will be
better to refuse this and tell them to
go away and come back with the design
that actually meets the needs of the
villages and and doesn't go against the
parish plan I think you can sir
I just confirm on the plan that's been
adopted by the district council that is
that is accepted now it is a it is an
accepted plan we are now starting a
neighborhood plan that would also one of
these this facility would be included in
that neighborhood plan as we move
forwards and identified as housing for
the village and on that housing need did
you identify the type of housing all the
scale it's about four or five years old
no that has a need survey we did - we
did an open market housing and and
housing needs survey and officers have
all the details for that but they
identified that the need is for family
homes and for homes for rental that is
what is is we are crying out for in the
village not a care home okay thank you
from the top left hand corner and it
come on stand outside the site there and
then down and comes down onto the new
road down the blocks on where he turns
at 90 degrees the footpath they used to
go straight across there going about 30
40 years before the Catholic school was
built in the house school is extended
and it was moved then even further used
to go across the middle of the high
school field so the footpath is not an
historical one for a good section of its
route it has been removed and we think
it would be much better and far better
for the village far better for the
school kids that walk them down there be
cheaper for the county council to
operate because there always happen to
cut the hedges back a little bit
Thank you Thank You Chancellor beam I've
got a few questions and forgive me while
you aren't some consular car girls
question I was making notes and
considering housing a phrasing it you
might have already answered this you
said that you'd identified this site for
housing did you identify how many houses
it should take an informant makes no it
was just a mix that would actually meet
the housing needs in the village and I
think we want something like 27 I think
he's what was in the last house I need
sir that was what was the 27 is for the
for all of sadly yes all for this site
that was for the hazy need at that time
we think this site we could accommodate
probably 25 to 30 houses I think so
you're higher up yet yeah I think you
said you'll your housing needs service
five years old yes
is it so you're judging from what you've
just said you don't think it's still in
date you may need to be need for more
are you gonna be redoing that anytime
soon the as soon as we start on the
neighborhood plan that will be one of
the first jobs is a new housing needs
survey along with lots of other surveys
of requirements so that that will be one
of the first jobs to get done and given
that would you expect there to be a and
identified need for extra care or for
housing for the elderly given whether
population we are very well looked after
for an extra church in the village we've
got four acres and Osprey house and
we've got another care home it's on the
austere Road so there are in area parish
councils opinions sufficient
opportunities for residents to actually
get care within the village yes they
held an open day in the village hall the
first time that came to pass Council and
four chillers are already so
Oh God couldn't make that one well
fortunately for me it wasn't holiday we
attended the the session in the village
hall and I put our views across and they
also then came and presented the first
council and we gave their views there
but this is what we've ended up with
some improvements but not what we asked
for okay thank you thank you thank you
right there has been I believe some a
bit of confusion I think the tech
timbala so I apologize sorry Tim that's
the next item the next person on the
agenda is our Gillings the agent over
three minutes and you're in time thanks
chairman members thank you very much for
allowing me to speak this evening my
name's Anna Gillings I'm the planning
consultant for the project so as
elevated from the report the scheme
seeks to provide a 65 bed care home for
the elderly and up to 10 new homes the
care home is designed to be dual
registered which means it could provide
both nursing or residential care and the
new homes are an outline form which
provides the ability to fix the mix the
design and the layout a preserved matter
stage while still providing certainty on
the access point now I just wanted to
highlight three points firstly on the
principle and as their parish plan isn't
a development plan document we've looked
at need as part of our assessment as one
of the first things we do when we come
to a new site and we actually identify a
massive shortfall it's about 360 beds
within a 5 K radius it's massive as you
know we're all getting older and the
need only increases and it's right that
care should be provided in a range of
forms that can go from shelter to extra
care to nursing homes but there is a
place for nursing homes that are
providing care for those frail elderly
people at the last three years of life
that type of arrangement this
application provides the opportunity to
help meet with that specific need within
the village
secondly the footpath which goes on the
outside which isn't in our ownership
it's not a great environment we
absolutely see that and that's largely
because it's narrow it's dark and it has
been very overgrown and as the parish
council say it does cause problems
locally the application provides the
ability to try and improve that route by
by brightening it up taking the route
round the outside but reducing their
landscaping putting in railings putting
in bollard lighting so that the scheme
turns its face on the footpath rather
than its back on the footpath and just
giving the residents the ability to
watch the community go past and bring it
into the scheme as I say it's not in our
control the way the land ownership works
out on actress enclose we can't take it
through the site because it would need
to come out on a piece of adopted
Highway and actually enclose isn't
adopted and we have to take into account
the the security of our residents in
forming a secure boundary for those
people who might have dementia and need
to be kept safe and just in terms of
layout and scale we have worked with the
parish council the first scheme we
promote here to us for a three storey
steam and we have taken it down to two
and two and a half as a response to the
comments we've received 30 seconds
please and I think as the officer says
it's a it's it's a scheme that now
reflects what Studley deserves which is
a high quality scheme in the centre of
the village so as it says the
application helps me to really
significant need for the care with a
great design building the new homes can
provide those family homes that have
been mentioned by the parish and we've
listened hard throughout the
consultation amended the scheme and
really reflected the positive and
proactive where your councillors dealt
with it okay thank you there's any
questions Catherine tell me a bit more
about the assessment you've done for the
need for the care home so the process we
go through is we use national
consultancy called Christie's and their
big firm they work out the number of
essentially what the demand is within a
5k catchment and
ten K catchment that 2017 biggest 22 22
and 20 27 and that looks at both current
beds which are without making a judgment
on the existing provision that can be in
converted Victorian dwellings they can
be substandard in terms of sizes ensuite
facilities things like that so we look
at what we call effective market
capacity beds which is the figure that's
in the reports which is about those beds
that are reaching the required standards
and as I say that shortfall is 350 s
it's big and between the two sites
between the proposed ten dwellings and
the care home what's what's going there
is that a wall of that fence landscaping
it's a fence line which forms part of
the full application for which condition
can be applied to control the materials
but equally whatever comes forward on
the outline side can affect that
boundary - thank you the how many people
you're hoping to employ there or the and
therefore what is the capacity for car
parking and therefore with the school
being there there is the problem of cars
leaving and young people around so what
if what thoughts have you got for the
number of people who were working there
so we met with the school and had the
chair of Governors and a lovely group of
pupils who talked us through how the
relationship works
they're quite keen on seeing the site
developed the things as long as they can
have their balls back home and what they
told us is that problem of of parking
along pool road the idea is that there
are 51 full-time equivalent jobs spread
over a shift period so that reddit their
staff don't sleep on site so the about
20 or so staff per shift ish and there
are spaces there for visitors and for
staff in addition to a staff travel plan
which is controlled by condition and the
house authorities that makes me happy
provision I think you can't just pick up
on that point what is the age range of
the residence at your anticipated in
this home because you mentioned the last
I think correct if I'm wrong three years
of life but I don't believe that you're
your age range is it isn't proposed to
be restricted because obviously if you
have early onset dementia you might need
to come in earlier than you might
otherwise need to if you come in later
on into life so generally what we say is
that the care home is there for people
in that very frail part of the life
matter what age they might be when they
get there so it's not restricted you're
very happy for the lighting to be
conditioned it's really important that
that bollard lighting that we're
proposing around the edge of the
footpath is carefully controlled is
low-impact and nobody wants floodlights
and yeah we're very happy to control
that as far as the authority we want to
thank you chairman just looking at the
the way that the care home is situated
on the site there is no real pedestrian
or easy pedestrian access to to the
center of Studley I mean you've got a
looks like a dead end on a chasm close
and obviously the the private housing
there doesn't seem to be a way through
am I correct because people wanting to
walk to the center of Stoli are going to
have a bit of a route march from there
where if they just went through the site
and actually onto well where pilot court
is you're you're a hop skip and a jump
from the main road and the shops I think
you can go both ways so as I understand
what happens at the moments the big
block that you can see just above it
just in places the doctor surgery then
the car park and what there's a clear
route through the car park around the
edge of the village hall and then back
down onto the high street further up in
the village
and as I understand it the the footpath
gets used both by there's the school
well everybody but people going across
waves and upwards and downwards see the
village you don't really think that
having a more direct access to the high
speed would be preferable I think it's a
well located site in the middle of the
village and actually you can access the
facilities relatively easy by foot thank
you how's it holding having inspected
the site that today that that building
is in some respects is much taller than
the surrounding buildings
the schools are low single-story the
doctors surgery is one and a half
stories this is going to be very
imposing on the street scene and have
you got an occupy foreign sources
suspect build to answer those two
questions is it possible to have the
layout back so in terms of what you'll
see from the street scene on the pool
Road side you'll see in just the end of
the building which is designed to have
that gable on so it doesn't look too big
and the view from the back actually is
quite a long way from those back houses
to look out onto so and with the
landscaping and the lighting and
everything that goes in between that I
think with we were comfortable and I
think the case of us was comfortable
with the scale of that and in terms of
an operator we at four I up for frontier
States we are developers not operators
it's the way we do it across the country
we we obtain planning permission and
then we work with an operator who will
then take it forward
I can't I'm not in a position to tell
you that operator is just at the moment
but it's that this is a standard process
as we go forward I think you can just
application please the the mix of the
mix of the housing then the type of
tenure that you're proposing
and the important thing is that the mix
is illustrative it's not controlled by
condition its L sorry it is controlled
by condition it's not fixed now so if
there a future developer or the parent
family housing they can have family
housing it's a mix at the moment I think
of two three and four but as I say it's
flexible the only thing we're seeking to
control is as up to ten which is just
about what you can fit on the back bit
of the site okay thank you
speakers council right thank you in some
ways I'm going to reiterate a lot of
what's already being said and there's no
doubt it's very close to facilities and
what we actually need but what is
misleading about it on that site and it
wasn't really showing up in the
photographs it has a great deal of
openness that's right it's one of the
few open areas in Studley itself and
what we're looking at is mass and
density and I don't feel that secure in
the parish done even says it that we
want more mass and density so from a
building perspective I really do object
to it and one of the things that the
enthalpy f says quite clearly we need to
be sensitive to the defining
characteristics of the local area
therefore again I'll come back to this
question of having openness and an
ability to see the village as it is and
then I would question the need for the
actual medium they've proposed in 68
houses currently at this very minute as
we speak
another 68 are being built in Studley so
that's a hundred and three
three plus the ones on the Ulster Road
plus the ones up at the slough so we're
building up quite a large number of care
homes and what we're doing is ignoring
the needs of younger people because if
you look at our population make up our
core strategy is we need development
means growth now how do we get growth
we're doing by encouraging a mix of
population that has needs
right across the board not just one
particular section but may or may not
one of the reasons I wanted to point
this the population out it's in total
it's seven point eight percent of sixty
plus people at the last census data live
in Studley now that was in 2011 so our
people are getting old so that the ones
that need care are already over aware
but the major and most prominent age
bound in snuggly which is twenty two
point three point eight percent
it's the forty five years to fifty nine
year olds just the very age then you age
where they've got children looking for
housing but will actually propose and
push what the district council itself is
sister is seeking is that development
means growth and I honestly don't feel a
mass building closing off openness is
going to take that forward or provide
for the needs in the village itself so I
would like if it is possible to reject
this planning application and write the
parish council take into account the
needs of the population and consider
what housing should be available on that
site that seems very regional and
retained openness that are already X's
not get rid of its main characteristic
or sensitivity to it sounding the fact
that it looks there it is neither year
over there it's an open site want to
retain it wanted
the needs of the population whose do
bear in mind to fill these beds people
are going to have to come from all over
the place because studly population
isn't going to provide it and there is
enough evidence that shows that if you
take people when they're very vulnerable
and put them in a very strange place
visitors don't come as often and they
actually deteriorate
we need a mixture of housing too so I
would appreciate this are you against
the principle of unemployed that's fine
I think members are any other questions
counsel Barnes ask you this obviously
therefore it doesn't go along with what
the parish plan thank you thank you okay
thank you very much sir thank you good
just turn the microphone Thank You
members um technical questions Castle
reduce thank you
heard from the applicant about an
assessment of need for this is that
something that's been presented to you
and or is it something that we conduct
ourselves or do take you on face value
and they presented a report with the
application documents which is referred
to in the committee report as I have
made reference to I don't have any
evidence to disprove the findings of the
report which do identify this need for a
care home thank you any other technical
questions um we're happy with the type
of tenure are we looking at the the
proposed private ten homes that they're
proposing on their obviously this is an
outlying application at this stage but
how would it be worded is it worded up
to ten for example as a maximum yes
that's correct so condition for as
recommended would require a maximum of
ten dwellings on the site and then we
also have a condition requiring the mix
to be agreed at condition ten so that
would be where we would ensure that the
the mix of dwellings is appropriate and
is in line with the knees which have
been identified by the parish in the
ward member of course watch this one
before the fencing down the middle
splits the site we heard from the
applicant again that if the women when
the reserve mattress comes through to
the ten that fencing could be reassessed
essentially is that correct if it is are
we able to put a condition on to prevent
it becoming open up
I've got no issue with there being some
form of access for access but I don't
want to see is it becoming a rat run for
people going through and on to the other
side yeah so I've basically got a
condition for both a care home and the
dwelling site requiring the submission
and approval of boundary treatment I
would expect it to be completely
partitioned off because of the
requirements of the care home ie if it
has got to mnsure sufferers to not allow
open access easily through by
pedestrians let alone vehicles so that
is something which would be controlled
by condition so it's conditioned that
it should be presented to us of reserved
matters it's not condition now but we
get to reserve matter stage that is
obviously part of thinking when we come
to approve condition eight of the up
sorry condition for the care home number
twenty-six that does require it to be
discharged through a condition just so
we've got control over the care home
element and the the outline element
through the reserve matters got it thank
you
Thank You chair just just looking at the
care home and the amount of
accommodation there are certain the
amount of units simply awful lot of car
parking I mean it looks at me like it's
you know a dozen possibly fifteen I
would have thought that a car parking
provision for a development of this size
with obviously a lot of visitors coming
and what-have-you it just seems to be a
little bit on the low side aisle perhaps
you could comment yes of course so and
26 car parking spaces are proposed and
so we've got the data from the applicant
in terms of the number of staff which
would be occupying the site at any one
time around about twenty we're satisfied
as officers that the level of parking is
appropriate in this case and the highway
authority haven't raised objection to
the development on the basis of lack of
parking because was taken into
consideration visitors then because it
looks to me as though it's just big
enough but but what we need for the
staff and whatever but you know they do
our business in town sometimes yeah
offices have had regard to staff
visitors and potentially residents
although that's obviously unlikely for
the type of use and occupation okay any
other technical questions right I can
open it for debate characters can
severely thank you and as we heard from
the parish council there is there has
been identified need for 27 homes
already and that's five years
out-of-date so inevitably there will be
a need for more this meets a third just
over a third of the current need
there is also been an identified need of
care services care homes a 300 boat
shortfall we've heard as our case
officers pointed out we've had a report
for two that and there's nothing to
refute that so evidently there is a need
for that as well I was slightly confused
by the ward members comments that she
would prefer to see a mix of housing and
care because it's an alternate purpose
that's exactly what we've got I actually
would I'm entirely happy with the
assessment of the that our case officers
made note proposed that with grants in
line with officer recommendation thank
you I have afraid I'm the opposite on
this one I think it's it's a large in an
area which is low building low site at a
very busy road with people going in out
of the car park opposite it would be far
better to make it or keep it as a
residential unit going out through the
old exit from the where the industrial
unit went out which I presume is on to
the road to the right hand side there
yes I understand what counsel Wright's
saying we've got doctors searching the
opposite side of the road the main thing
that were they're trying to do now is to
keep people in their own homes as long
as possible
so therefore if you've got a mixture of
bungalows and affordable homes if we can
persuade the developer to do that then
it's much better than have a large block
that I think is blighting the street
scene thank you I'm struggling on this
one as well the reason is that obviously
councillor fielding said quite rightly
that there is a the the policy is for
people to be in their own homes however
if you're suffering from dementia
serious onset of dementia accepted then
you have to have care so I fully accept
that and I see there is a knee to that
my concern is the identified need now
obviously we've had report that's been
submitted by the applicants
the perhaps on the other hand have
actually said they don't have an
identified need and the consequence to
that is I I am unhappy without seeing
that and I would personally I would
rather defer this item until with with
me now to scrutinize that report and in
the wider area the reason I actually
saying this one is because if we had an
experience in Ulster which is only a few
miles away and that was we have quite
quite sufficient care in that we need
extra care I don't get me wrong but the
other type of care which we're looking
at I'm just really uncomfortable I would
prefer to defer this and then scrutinize
that report and that would be my
proposal that obviously we have a for a
primary you know one first Caliburn so
because I'm concerned about the size
bulk and mass of this building and I'm
looking at the site it was sort of a
very open site appreciate it's probably
the right place to have it not far from
the doctor's but then I've got two three
care homes now in my area and they've
got no parking they've got all the
quality of parking they've got the
amount of parking and still they're over
full people keep coming and there's
nowhere to park we may be legally right
and as far as I can see the houses have
gone along with the parish plan but the
other bit isn't whether that's the
reason for refusal but cancer carries
the adjoining member has a number of
concerns not for refusal but I'm not
ever happy if it was in my patch because
along Thank You chairman I think like
most I'm I'm very mixed on this I really
do take the the opinion of the parish
council and the fact that this site in
their opinion would be better for normal
and affordable housing in in the usual
way okay having said that I can
understand
perhaps there is a need for this type of
development but again just looking at
the site and looking at the size of this
care home I'm not bothered about the
housing that seems fine it's the scale
of this home it's it just strikes me to
be too big and there was a very very
important point that I think it does
detract in the openness of this part of
Studley it will be a very overbearing
building I just think in this case the
application is trying to squeeze too
much accommodation onto too small an
inappropriate site so I am struggling to
go with the officers recommendation on
this for that point cocooning going on
what councillor bonds is referred to as
parking problems I can see that visitors
will overspill into the car park
opposite which was filling up as I was
waiting for councilor carriage to turn
up for parents taking and collecting
their children from school so all it is
doing is creating a traffic problem
there which shouldn't really be
necessary because there's a perfectly
good exit going from the other end of
the site yes I understand the comments
with regards to care but it can be much
better planned and I agree with what
fellow councillors are saying that he it
does need to keep that openness that is
there from low-rise buildings in the
area thank you other any other comments
on this one councillor Richards we have
a proposal do we have a seconder for
that I'm afraid that particular one
fails do we have another cult a
counterproposal that's right I had a
kind of I had the counter proposal we
should to defer now I have got of
picking up the point that council Lawton
and councillor fielding said and
Casavant about League sized Balkans cow
I'm actually willing to withdraw that
proposal for the moment so do I have
another proposal
yes Jeff I'm for the reasons that I
stated before that this is an
inappropriate site for this type of
development and the development proposed
this is too bulky I would propose that
we refuse this planning application
Thank You Catalans
I'm caught up in a second that's in the
restrictive I was thinking of ever in
deferment I do believe a smaller
building which means less parking would
be more appropriate there so the only
way I can get that is to refuses and
over secondly members the vote before
use to refuse planning permission for
1703 slash outline Barbara works all
those in favor against this committee
therefore resolves to refuse plain flesh
of 1700 300 3/4 and so following on from
council Orton's proposal I got as a
result of it the inappropriate the site
being an appropriate for this type of
development and it being too bulky and I
think in terms of the too bulky
I think it's bulk of masses the word
said too bulky but more than happy I've
written down too large out of scale size
bulk and mass to tracks from openness
and that would be against policy cs9 of
the core strategy and so that one's more
simple in terms of the inappropriate
site are you able to just elaborate in
terms of what you mean by being
inappropriate site for this type of
development please what I meant is it is
more an appropriate site for for
standard private and affordable housing
its location that in where it is he
there are better locations for care
homes within studly if he could be
proven that the loss sufficient demand I
would also add in in relation to the
bulk and whatever that the bulk of the
building the amount of accommodation
there precludes where I I disagree with
a district
couple other son of the County highways
opinion I don't think is enough car
parking for a development of this size
perhaps we could include that yeah by
all means if members aren't satisfied
with the level of parking or so we can
do that against policy CS twenty six and
I'm just struggling in terms of I
understand where you're coming from in
terms of it being an inappropriate site
but I just can't think what policy
against which or the reason why it's
inappropriate so if you could either
provide me with a policy or we stick
with the design and two CS nine and
parking at the CS twenty-six
happy with the just will go with those
okay and second well we've got you know
not now because we brought you debated
it and it wasn't part and part of the
debate oh yeah I was gonna say to you
chairman I think all of actually patent
before we took the vote so into my way
of thinking our Constitution requires us
to have the vote again having read
abated the thing I would suggest that we
do that it might be a formality but I
would suggest you do that through that
we've identified those items now it's
down to Council or to me to enunciate
those as part and possibly proposal
we've already taken a vote without
having had those enunciated that which
is incorrect in terms of Constitution
and don't say well if you wish to go
through that beareth then what we'll do
we'll say cows a lot and are you happy
with what you've just we've been
discussing and do we want to go through
the vote yes we'll go through vote
I think chair just for the point of
clarity if Alice we please just read out
the reasons that we are going to refuse
so we're all clear on that and then I'm
quite happy to have another vote so just
pick you up on the debate and I've got
that the proposed care home is too large
out of scale by reason of size well and
my master tracks from the openness of
the area so that would be refusal
against policy cs9 of the core strategy
and members are unsatisfied that there's
a sufficient level of parking on the
site which would be roughly usual
against policy cs 26 of the core
strategy okay so we're going to say a
vote on but basis with those proposals
all those in favor against thank you
this committee therefore to refuse
playing fish of 1703 403 stretch out
thank you thank you
well make
five minute recess thank you
buddy come here move on thank you
everybody
right the next item on the agenda is
16/2 666 the former Murray Corelli
school playing field and the presenting
officer is Oh Thank You chairman the
application site which denoted by the
black dot in the center of the plan is
located within the built-up area of
stratford-upon-avon the application
relates to a vacant piece of land within
the bishops an area of Stratford
residential development lies to the
north east and south of the site with
bishops and primary school to its west a
public footpath lines the eastern
boundary of the site full planning
permission is sought for a development
comprising seventy-five two bears units
of extra care accommodation the primary
means of a clear access to the site
would be via Corelli closed with an
entrance for service vehicles from
bishops closed as well as the 75 units
of accommodation communal facilities to
include residents lounge and catered
dining room would be provided on-site
the development range from one and a
half stories to two and a half stories
and would be constructed in a mix of
brick render and timber cladding the
development takes advantage of varying
levels across the site and the middle
elevation shows how the development
would appear from Bishop's close the top
elevation shows the same view but cut
through the site and the bottom
elevation the view from Corelli close
and here the west and east elevations of
the development as viewed from the
primary school and the public footpath
the applicant has provided a
visualization of the proposed apartment
which gives an indication of the finish
of the proposal this photo is taken from
the southern edge of the site looking
toward Bishop's in primary school and
the dwellings on Corelli close and
panning around the site in the context
of the dwellings on Crowley clothes can
be seen and panning around a bit more
the dwellings on Corelli close on the
left-hand side of the slide with the
rear elevations of the dwellings on
heather close on the right-hand side of
the slide this photo is taken from
Bishop's close the site but being behind
the fence and boundary trees this photo
is taken from the public footpath to the
east of the site
and here from Corelli close members
should note that there are a couple of
updates of the application which are
detailed within the update sheet
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to the
conditions and financial contributions
as detailed within the committee report
the provision of a financial
contribution to a public open space
would only be secured if specific
schemes can be identified by the Town
Council if no scheme to identify the POS
contribution would not be secured as it
would not be still compliant thank you
thank you other speakers are grace Allen
the agent and Tim Willis
three minutes meantime good evening my
name is Grace Allen I am the agent on
behalf of the applicant good evening my
name is Tim Willis I'm the extra care
housing program lead from Orange County
Council housing care 21 is the leading
national provider of retirement housing
and care services for older people
mainly those aged 65 and above they are
nonprofit organization with a social
purpose and operating over 150 local
authorities including many districts
across Warwickshire
they promote independence and choice for
older people through good quality
affordable housing care and support just
to be clear this is not a care home the
extra care has been provided by the
applicant encourages independent living
but we support where residents need it
extra care schemes are also generally
occupied by people already in the local
area rather than people even from
outside the district this reduces
additional pressures on existing health
and other services if approved the
development will provide 75
self-contained apartments within a wider
facility by a care and support is
available on-site there will be
community facilities including a
hairdressers restaurant and community
event evenings the applicant will
actively encourage Bishop to residents
to engage in the proposed scheme is
fully supported by your local planning
policies this includes policy CS 19 of
the core strategy which specifically
supports extra care housing for elderly
people in addition to approved
consultation events we've worked closely
with your officers and other
stakeholders and the proposals have
evolved as partners close working to
ensure a very high quality development
that meets all relevant policies housing
care 21 intent pride as much affordable
housing on this site as possible which
would be significantly higher than 35%
normally required in housing schemes the
applicant will work in collaboration
with a local authority to ensure the
affordable housing residents are means
tested in terms of all of the disability
but crucially they have a local
connection to the immediate locality
housing care 21 will apply for grant
funding from homes England should your
decision to approve this application
this grant will maximize the level of
affordable housing able to be provided
as part of the scheme along with the
supporting various sexual ethics
contributions requested towards open
space healthcare and trance
got the post aged care scheme will
deliver important benefits the housing
needs the district's aging population
requiring portable care it also fully
costs local and national policies and we
respectfully request that you endorse it
offer this recommendation and support
the application snapshot of extra care
housing ladies and gentlemen versus
residential care when I consult with all
the people our most vulnerable citizens
I ask for questions
who in this room wants to live in
residential care who has seen a
residential care home they want to put
their name down for who wants to stay at
home for the rest of their lives with a
package of care to support them if you
can't have that who wants to live in an
apartment flat own front door with
access to care 24/7
that is extra care housing which has
been in warranty now since 2010 in 2017
with nine scheme 632 units we were able
to say house fall we have no more extra
care housing in September 2017 we
started once again to divert people into
residential care because we cannot offer
extra care housing until we can we will
be diverting people to to residential
care
we need schemes not just in bishop tune
we need them in Studley we need them in
Ulster we need them in ship stand we
need them across the county we need
units by 2020 thank you the ten you mix
that we've seen rolled out across other
schemes is rent and shared ownership so
if you look at briar Croft
you've got your rental and shared
ownership model there if you look at
tide lodge you've got your rent and
shared ownership
there if you look at Arden courts are
currently under construction again
you've got the rent and shared ownership
model there well if we have a condition
on this name is that not happy because I
think with the market and with the LH a
cap which is reduced rents I think we
have to be realistic and acknowledge
that in order to make a scheme viable
there has been a need this is a national
issue
I've seen some outright sale being
introduced into the mix not opening the
door for outright sales and you can be
sure that I will be stood shoulder to
shoulder and didn't to stop that but
this is aimed we tended for this aiming
at the Warwickshire County Council
social care customer either the current
or the prospective customer cousin coach
lovely thank you just mister point dad
this is extra care studly was a care
home
so is it very different things and I are
very much convinced by these figures for
the need for extra care as opposed to
care homes which you've just told us
about there's no on that we will this
came to us when I read this 69%
affordable that was great that was
lovely and now we have a will do the
best we can
above 35 35 is good but 69 was lovely
can you I don't think I need some
reassurances that it's going to be
towards a 69 or some explanation about
where you are you mentioned a grant so
without the grant are you saying you can
do 35 or can you do more than 35 so can
you give us some specific amounts about
how bigger this percentage will be
depending on what grant you get and can
I also hear from Tim on his opinion on
what you're just about to say the reason
that we have to
it's going to be above 35% it's because
of the sexual Mystics contributions
requested and with those and without the
grant the applicant would be able to
find that many affordable and because
the application has been in so long the
previous funding has slipped so we can
reapply for that but we don't know how
much that will be at the moment so once
you've got that we'll be able to just to
say exactly how many we can provide I
mean just offer some reassurance
counselor we with all you know the
department's at County be pushing for
what exactly we tended for which was the
affordable housing model we need to
acknowledge that it needs that the
viability issues within that and I think
there will be some quite significant
discussions as I understand it we're not
specifically looking at tenure this
evening but you have my assurance and I
hope that sort of working with your
office's to do that we will be pushing
for as many affordable units on that
site as it's possible to deliver I'd
like to see more than 69 I would like to
really crank it up towards the den I say
the hundred percent now that's really
sure but while you were saying that I've
just the in the report I think it was an
independent or Stratford had it had a
report done on the viability and they
came back said there was a shedload of
profit to be made on this and that the
viability wasn't really an issue so have
you got a comment on that it's a
question I will be asking to officers
later so this is your chance to sort of
counter that okay I'm not a viability
expert so I can't make any comment we
had a assessment done based on a theme
of 69 percent which showed that we
couldn't pay for the section 106
however the viability assessment done on
behalf of the council assessed a theme
of 35 percent affordable housing
therefore it's tough to chimerical
scheme so we would expect yes we can
provide 35 percent but we want to
provide more
okay Cassidy I can't consult okay
counselor fielding thank you
car parking the number of car parking
units have you got and doesn't meet our
proposed ruling that's coming out
shortly with regards to the number of
car parking spaces we would like to see
we're proposing 51 car parking spaces
she's currently in accordance with your
current parking proposed how many unit
7551 475 yes
so that's based on the current guidance
which says one space per four residence
apartments and hasn't cared to anyone
have their own design brief which says
one two three so we're well within those
guidelines
what's the room for visitors and say
we've got about thirteen thirteen
eighteen for staff and then the range
will be split between residents and
visitors the remainder between about 25
residents 13 to 18 for staff and the
rest of your visitors the other question
is the management of this assistant who
is going to earn it and who's going to
be doing the management is it gonna be
Warwickshire County Council managing it
because having been involved in property
management there's a very good way of
making a big profit by management fees
that can be added on but are these going
to be controlled or how can you control
them I can only refer
to the contractor Ranger and I should
point out this is one of six sites that
we tended housing care 21 take care of
the the housing management's of support
they also take care of the care type of
things so when we tendered we were
looking for operators to come in who
would take care of both the housing in
care site so it will rest without any
care 21 okay thank you very much thank
you all right any technical questions
sorry board board member is not speaking
I've discerned that so any technical
questions in yeah I thought I read that
we had a report that or someone who had
a report done saying that the viability
was there wasn't there was plenty profit
to be made and I've told that was based
on 35 not 69 and is you know it's really
anything we can actually I'm quite happy
with us just is that's the question okay
the question was did we do our viability
on 35 yes we did the reason being that
it's actually not a policy requirements
required 35% affordable housing on c2
units say if we were to say it was a c3
which extra care can fall within there
is a policy requirements provide 35 but
our view is there an additional or a
higher percentage of affordable housing
shouldn't mean that you don't have to
offset any additional strain on local
infrastructure so in this particular
case for example contributions to the
NHS the type of development that this is
is likely to give rise to extra pressure
hence the reason for the NHS request so
I accept the argument to a degree that
obviously higher affordable housing
means is less in the part but officers
view in Waiting it was that actually if
we were to stick to a 35 percent
affordable housing we still achieve
affordable housing but it doesn't put
pressure on the local infrastructure
without any sort
negation so do we work with County
Council on this obviously county
councillor envisaging as higher
proportion as possible how can we assist
that as a district council and County
Tim Willis in his role as extra care
program leader at County Council will be
involved in sort of the drafting for one
and six as well John Gordon as the
development and enabling officer so we
will be working with them to ensure that
as high a proportion as possible is
provided on-site you could bear with me
one moment
I'm sorry
sorry about that and because the use is
c2 and therefore there's not a policy
requirement for any affordable housing
we would not be looking to put
specifically in the 106 a certain
percentage of affordable housing we can
obviously put the note on as suggested
earlier that we want it to be as high as
possible but I think it would be
difficult to say that we have to come
back and clear through committee a
different level of affordable housing
given that there's actually no policy
hook for that well for me for me there's
no point having this here unless it's
providing what the district needs and
what the district needs is affordable
it needs some private but it needs
affordable that's that's the prime aim
of what what the county want and I think
what the district should want so you
know I would like it to be discussed
with Tim and and policy and whoever and
potentially with the portfolio holder
that we have on the committee here and I
would really like it if people are not
happy for it to come back because that
is a benefit which which might outweigh
other things so I think it's the benefit
of affordability although not required
is a benefit that goes toward granting
this and I think it's relevant I think
the only alternative I could suggest is
that once we know what the percentage is
likely to be that we run it via
councilor Cargill as chair and then if
he considers it to be appropriate he
could potentially call it back to
planning committee so might minor issues
are the is the footpath going to be
improved
which is mentioned here there was some
talk about bringing the fencing back the
the footpath would remain as currently
aligned it's just got a picket fence
along the side of it at the moment so
there's not a huge amount to improve
it's it's quite a good footpath I think
it was just what share rights-of-way
team were concerned because they were
proposing a closed board fence along the
entirety which will create quite a
tunnel so we obviously want to avoid
that but subject conditions are detailed
in the agenda
I'm satisfied that that can be sorted to
ensure the design of that fencing is
appropriate can you tell me the view
from Heather close is it if I can just
clarify this is bishops clothes here
this is Corelli these are the backs of
dwellings on how the clothes so what is
it this elevation you want to that
station this one here doing a half story
right
going back on to car parking space are
you satisfied that there is enough car
parking space if not is there a good
pedestrian access to buses and other
facilities within the town and as page
53 of your agenda a car parking
statement was submitted with the
application which outlined the level of
parking proposed and how that was
arrived at it states it was on the basis
of research into levels of car ownership
with an existing extra care
accommodations as well as the level of
car usage amongst staff associated to
the use of the sites in addition the
highway Authority has also had regard to
the level of parking proposed and having
considered other extra care developments
within the county it concludes that the
level of parking is likely to be
sufficient for the demands of the
proposed development in light of that
I'm satisfied that level of parking is
acceptable and obviously on that point
of public transport we are in a very
sustainable part of the town in Bishop's
and in Stratford so there's easy access
by foot bus routes and then to train
routes from their agenda is that them
the the footpath game is that the
footpath that you are showing there that
goes down to the main road yes this is
the path yeah
okay thank you right open to billet 280
cattle bones this 35% on all the
relevance for affordable to Brent
applies to this site like any other side
it doesn't know just to confirm it see
scar see - so there's no requirement
outright to provide we can't put a
condition on it counsel Alton okay okay
anyone else debate no Thank You chair I
really like this I think the design is
excellent I like the way that the lowest
buildings are situated on the the
highest part of the site unlike previous
applications this car parking ratio is
proportionately almost 60 or 70% better
I'm quite happy with it I think it ticks
all the boxes German and I'd be more
than happy to propose that we accept the
proposal as I've landed in the he report
Thank You carriages I'm happy to second
that I completely agree with what
council Orton has just said and also if
- if it helps to put Chancellor
carriages mind at rest I'm quite happy
to be involved in the negotiation when
it comes to affordable housing
cows bones I'm happy is wrong okay right
um I would say something that I have had
dealings with Tim and I know that he
will go for as many affordable units as
is possible so I'm quite happy to do
that and as I have said I'm I'll be
involved with with the portfolio holder
on that one remember we did say about a
note are you happy with including the
note that we discussed there absolutely
Kevin all right anything else
can I just clarify chairman D so that
the affordable housing is the proposal
that will see what the applicant is
proposing and then if you're happy with
that then you know you can issue a
decision if you're not happy then it may
need to come back yeah
any other members right thank you then
members the vote before use to grant
plan commission 416 five oh two six six
six slash fall all those in favor this
committee this committee never resolves
to grant time for 16 - oh two six six
six five four including the notes that
we have discussed thank you
thank you everybody
I'm moving on because I have a long
agenda this evening I'd like to move on
to the next item the item is 1702 nine
more months - Paul and that is land
adjacent to the lodge doors into Manor
dossing tum' and James is our presenting
officer on this one
apologies we're just trying to find the
the actual presentation such as one
moment please
apologies sir we're going to try and
find the finally the file for that one
we will come back to that in a few
moments so Pontius
right in that case then we'll move on to
item 50 item 6 thank you which is 17 / 0
to 7 for 7/4
Darci cottage High Street born on Aven
and Shawn is our presenting officer
okay Thank You chair this relates to an
application at Darcy cartagene well
Fattah Navin its pages 57 to 63 of your
agenda it's a part retrospective
application for construction of walls
and gates at the front of Darcy cottage
the low walls and gate posts have been
constructed the gates remain proposed
and I'm not currently in place so this
is our slide number one the OS plan the
black arrow shows the location of Darcy
cottage in the village the High Street
runs north-south sure if you can see my
cursor with Barton Road off to the west
okay so here we have our location plan
with Darcy Cottage outlined in red the
extent of the village conservation area
in pink and the public footpath stashed
in green and the rebels into the listed
buildings so here we have the existing
and proposed street seeing plans showing
the we haven't we had a hedging place
here we have replacement hedge and
showing the the existing five-bar gate
which is now to be replaced with low
walls and timber gates
apologies sorry here we have the site
plan comparing the existing to the
proposed the gates will be set back
around five meters from the edge of the
public highway
low walls here of one meter in height
and agates agates there and a close-up
detail of the proposed gates and walls
again the walls will be about a meter in
height the gate posts 1.7 and the gates
themselves 1.8 meters in height moving
on to the photographs that's an
up-to-date photograph of Darcy cottage
at the moment the hedge in here on the
left of the photograph is quite new it's
just been replaced and you can see the
low walls and the gatepost since it's
you there and again looking north up the
main high street in Welford this
photograph also show shows home B
cottage just there to the right of the
photo thatched cottage which is listed
and again another photograph of the site
showing ash cottage here which is to the
south and another close-up photo of the
walls and post it's a bit of a street
scene shot again looking north there's a
purple local precedents that have been
set in and around Welford for boundary
treatments this is opposite Darcy
cottage so we've got a close border
fence there just on the corner of High
Street and Barton Road and a brick wall
there as well some timber gates just
down the road at barn dale and again
this is just opposite the village shop
cider mill house just south of our
application sites we've got these gates
and painted wall that's the old royal
house so that is the end of the
presentation
there are a couple of updates which
relate to the conditions one condition
has been removed it was no longer
required and it related to an amended
plan that was received and an additional
condition has been suggested which
relates to the I go back probably at
best on that which relates to the
lighting yeah so Thank You chair they've
wrecked the recommendations to grant
this application subject to those
conditions on the in the agenda and on
the update sheet thank you
speaker this evening is a mr. Nigel
Walker okay thank you thank you just
press up at the bottom are they and then
you have three minutes in your own time
great good evening councillors apologize
on those pictures the house is our
innovation so let's rather messier than
it would do normally in recent month my
wife and I have experienced a number of
security incidents where we've had
elements stolen from the drive random
people walking up the drive around the
house taking stuff from the house and
then recently in early summer Mossman in
broad daylight enter the property walked
around the property and kicked the front
door in with my wife in the house took
all the car keys and went off with a car
which is obviously quite a terrifying
experience as a result of which how we
wanted to improve the security the
property we've replaced the five our
gate with the pillars move the the
gatepost back three and a half four
meters an original point to allow better
access and also a pedestrian access
behind a new vehicle entering the
property and the police report from
warship police made some recommendations
of solid gates of up to one point meters
high primarily as you can see from the
picture there not that the five our gate
is is isn't an obstruction to a point
the problem being you can see right into
the garage into the drive and it's
basically
causing an issue in people be able to
see what is actually in the drive and
indeed in the garage any one time this
is resulted basically earns lost June we
can no longer leave any doors open in
the house the rear of the property the
garage door can't be kept open at any
time other than for access as and when
required then shut again because this in
full visibility over of a major junction
and I think we're all aware of the
situation happen on Monday the next-door
neighbor that Rogers shot before the
shot was attacked by five masked men
wielding a hammer so and another car was
still in the village this week alone as
well so it's a protective issue there's
firearms in the house and registered
firearm keeper obvious reasons another
reason to keep the house secure we've
replaced the hedge at the front as well
with a brand new you age which just
literally implanted in these thickening
out a bit and out obviously had added
protection obviously we commenced some
of the work understanding from the
contract and indeed the gate supplier
that it was approved work clearly it
wasn't so we stopped work immediately
early summer and obviously it made the
relevant alterations in conjunction with
discussing with Stratford County et
cetera that the planning covered all the
main elements that a planning officers
set out we also say located within a
conservation area were very mindful of
that Hornby cottage door one second
Springs but in light of obviously
precedent set very very close to our
current property and indeed in the
village we believe that what we've done
is in in light with the house and the
local area and doesn't doesn't hinder or
obstruct or destroy the current the
current of you okay thank you thank you
any questions on this thank you very
much Calabar do you wish to speak
would be the first ya don't feel you
need to look bad if I said I'd not
listen to say yes we are having
unfortunately a lot of break-ins the
gentleman said next door but one five
masked men one with a hammer that went
through some shady breed another one
went through a bottle of the knife went
through some cornflakes most parish
councils where we've had the problem in
Tom Marston and a Clippard of work with
the people to get it sort of security
well it's happened there were two great
balls went up six for time we have
negotiated through the applicant to get
what we feel it is appropriate and they
feel safe I suppose you can see that
it's been reduced substantially even the
height of the pillars out and as far as
I'm concerned it's a great shame that in
a rural area now this is we had three
two break-ins in la Martin last week
we've got one at Shepherd chambers where
it's got a 200-meter wall you know about
with electric fence on and my dog goes
under the gate to the guard dog to have
a word nobody else can get him but max
just go in so as far as I'm concerned we
don't want these big gates but I'm happy
to support it and I'm sorry that the
parish council that a broad ageia
haven't come to put their point of view
but we have worked together with the
applicant to get what we feel is
acceptable because what he put up first
wasn't an enforcement had it and the
planning officer has worked with myself
and the applicant to get what we think
is suitable and I see no reason why it
shouldn't be granted thank you sorry if
you have gone on one side it I just
questioning the point that you made
there about the parish council obviously
still great still maintaining objection
yet they've worked with
officer on this one so why didn't they
they haven't not as far as I know who
know the opposite will probably tell you
that we we together work on a lot of
application don't we do capsule balance
ya know the the parish council weren't
quite strong and maintaining the
rejection to this okay thank you right
counseling just a quick one the all the
other big tall gates we've seen are they
all in the conservation area the last
one I think you saw is 40 yards away in
that comes a basin area yes there are as
far as I know yes yeah okay the one
opposite that bond Ally the last one you
saw which is just the other side the
road and it's any technical questions of
the officer open to debate
Thanks
I've got no problem with the officers
recommendation here I propose that we go
with it my starting point is what we're
looking at here what would it do I
consider to be materially impact in the
conservation area the answer that is no
in reality they're fairly insignificant
pillars for security reasons so I'm
entirely happy to quite happy to second
that for exactly the same reasons is
absolutely nothing wrong with this
application remembers the vote before
you then is to grant a planning
permission for 1702 seven for seven such
for all those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resolves a grand plan pressure 17/2
seven four seven four thank you
what we're still awaiting the
presentation for 17 such otwo 9 1 1 so
we'll move on now to 17 so 2 6 3 om REM
which is pinehurst Oscar Road little on
all right thank you
Thomas over to you
right Thank You chairman the site is
indicated on the map by the black circle
the application situs is located in
little on on the Ulster Road and within
the open countryside it sits outside
from them it sits outside of the main
cluster of buildings within the
settlement but directly to a side of a
row for semi-detached properties
this slide shows the application site
edged in red the site would continue to
be accessed from Ulster aid to the front
which sits directly to the southeast of
the site the site is currently garden
land associated with Pinehurst the
2-story semi-detached dwelling which can
be seen directly to the southwest the
site shares its western boundary with
this property and the red line is within
the curtilage open fields about the site
to the north and east with a public
rider way running to the east of the
site this is indicated by the Green Line
the site is also within the West
Midlands green bow and the art and
special landscape area this is an
application for approval of reserved
matters these matters are access
appearance landscaping layout and scale
the application proposes a local needs
bungalow this plan shows the intuitive
layout showing outline stage under
application 16 / 0 to 5 3 9 / o UT this
also indicates the access point this
plan shows the proposed siting of the
new liked or needs bungalow
access will be provided via the existing
access of foster Road and a driveway
with parking and maneuvering area would
be provided within the site vehicle
access for Pinehurst would remain as it
was existing the bungalow would be sited
approximately 90 metres back from the
highway edge these plans show that the
proposed funding they would measure
thirteen point three meters in maximum
length 17.5 meters in width and
approximately five poem watt meters in
height
the bungalow would be pitched reef and
would feature three bedrooms and then
attached garage to the
side this would be set down from the
main reef the bungalow would be rendered
with a tiled reef this photo shows the
frontage of the site when viewed from
the Elster Road the existing access onto
the highway is visible as well as the
mature gardens behind a glimpse of
Pinehurst is also visible on the
left-hand side of the photo this photo
is taken from the same position but
facing southwest along the Ulster Road
you can see the row of four
semi-detached properties which have been
extended Pinehurst is our dwelling on
the right hand side of the photo the
site is just off screen to the right
this photo is taken from in front of
Pinehurst the site is visible centrally
within the site between the two cars the
access onto the highway is also visible
just to clarify there are no updates
officer recommendation is to grant the
application for reserved mutters subject
to the conditions and notes in the
report which can be found on pages 74 to
77 of the agenda thank you very much our
first speaker is counselor Chairman Liz
Lee Harvey Hagen counselor you have
three minutes in your own time just
press a button at the bottom of the base
there and then off you go thank you very
much chairman I'm good evening gentlemen
and ladies and first of all I'd like to
say that as a parish council we have
absolutely no objection to the
development of this site and in fact
came in front of the committee on appeal
last time this came before you and
permission was at that time recommended
to refuse but it was in subsequently
approved when we came to committee it is
our understanding that mr. mrs. flood
the applicants have tried to work quite
closely with Stratford district council
on the overall look of the bungalow the
proposed one go
but it appears from what we understand
that there has been some confusion in
terms of what advice that was and who it
was given from which we haven't been
able to completely clarify our
suggestion our situation is that whilst
we acknowledge and fully support the
development we believe that the
footprint of this one far exceeds that
of a local needs bungalow the basis on
which the application was made was that
it was a downsizing but if you look at
the footprint and compare it to the
existing location which is occupied by
the applicants we now have a three
bedrooms three ensuite big bedrooms a
study a living room a kitchen and we
think that if this is inherited by the
parish on a local needs basis it is
unlikely that someone in that position
would be able to afford the upkeep of
something like that I mean it's a it's a
supposition but it's probably a quite a
strong one so we believe that the scope
of what's before you is just too large
at the moment and we'd be far happier
with supporting perhaps a two bedroom or
a three bedroom but maybe one bathroom
or one ensuite in an extra bathroom but
squeezing it up a little bit and if you
go back to the visual you can see that
the footprint of that because it is a
bungalow is inevitably bigger but the
total footprint compared to the three
terraced cottages next to it is way more
than we believe is acceptable and also
we think it needs to come forward a bit
more so we'd like to see it more in line
with those other cottages rather than
setback that's what I've got to say
thank you very much thank you yes it is
we identified within the parish plan
which isn't completely approved yet it's
still in its final stages but it's been
through the parish it's approved by the
parish council it's just in the last
stages with your team
so yes we did identify the need for some
additional bungalows we did yeah just it
looks to me like a two-bedroom bungalow
with a study ah and that corner room is
a language there's a kitchen a diner
there's three bedrooms and something
which looks like it could be a bedroom
without a bed in it and then two two
identified bedrooms only one of them one
of those bedrooms with an ensuite no
there's the other one has an ensuite as
well we had a look at this quite
carefully
okay well I'll clarify that was a the
officers later the other thing is in the
report I think we're being told and I'll
clarify this with the officers later
that the footprint is very similar to
what was in the outline application I
know that mr. sideline
yes but gave an a an indicative
footprint which we're told is similar to
this one hmm
and the reason we we accepted it in the
first place was quite a lot to do with
the parish council support correct so
can you tell me why you think this is um
basically I think this is part of the
confusion we tried to clarify at the
start when this was an outline whether
or not we were tied by that drawing and
we were advised not so now that the the
final plans have come in front of us we
just believe it's too big that's all
thank you any other questions so the
principal you're happy with the
development is we would support mr. mrs.
rod in doing this completely and utterly
it's just we still feel it slightly big
okay thank you very much thank you
right
our next speaker is Micah flood the
applicant good evening you hear me yeah
three minutes in you're in times before
thank you
it's a little unusual I know that may I
take a few rooms of my time to thank
this committee for the compassionate way
you've dealt with my wife in the first
instance when she stood before you last
year it was a very low point in our
lives and your considerations were
really sincerely thanks suddenly we
haven't had opportunity to talk to our
post counsel regarding this application
finding out some about their objections
through the officer nevertheless we've
tried to do our best to meet their
concerns even though some of their
comments seem to be a little
unreasonable their suggestion of puttin
the building to the front of the road
where the wildlife ponds are is not
acceptable to us also their question
that they question that the application
is not downsizing every shrub tree
client paver in that garden has been put
there by us over the last 40 years
it needs looking after
and we feel that by cutting the garden
into and building a property that would
suit us on one side this is definitely
downsizing the officers have agreed that
citing the bond low further into the
site would mitigate the impact on the
surrounding Greenbelt and also the palms
trees and hedges to be retained
give me a limitation of a single story
bondola the footprint is larger than we
would have hoped however I insisted on
the s106 agreement so that if a home
Bill's here they wouldn't not only
slipped and needs in the relative short
term but can benefit a future local
family who may also have mobility needs
the design is a compromise and not
necessarily one we want or like it but
we accept that what is now proposed is
possibly the best we can do and we do
have you agree with it thank you any
questions Caitlin
yeah just just one briefly you mentioned
the wildlife pond is that a a natural
pond in the other bedroom there's a
study meant to be there available as a
bedroom or there is only one ensuite
bedroom in the major bedroom and the
study come whatever may be used as a
study for me to masturbate in or just
literally for a carer if we need one
okay members thank you very much in use
it look thank you all right no other
speakers so I'll go to technical
questions um I think the first I would
like to discuss obviously the local need
element just a clarification for me that
is in perpetuity is it not yes this is a
reserved mutters application for so the
matters that are at for consideration
our access appearance landscaping layout
and scale the local needs fungo element
the proposal was determined under the
principle of the online application
thank you
discuss the building line which has been
I think mr. flood discuss that briefly
are you happy to accept matter yes in
terms of the proposed bungalow it is
said it would be set back to puts many
19 meters from the highway frontage
which is approximately eight and a half
meters back from the front elevation of
Pinehurst so it certainly would be set
further back than the existing dwellings
along this part of the road but officers
considered that considering the the
width of the plot and also looking at
the landscaping which would be retained
as part of setting the bungalow back
within the site we considered that the
the citing further back is acceptable in
this case and wouldn't have a
considerate impact on on the community
of the area okay Richard just on clear
the size and citing as proposed is I
exactly how it was put to us from their
outline so this is the indicative plan
which was submitted to outline stage the
size of the bungalow at that stage was
shown to be just under one hundred and
fifty three square meters and the size
of the bungalow are shown into the
reserved matters application the owner
itself would be approximately one
hundred and fifty nine square meters
with their 24 square meters for the
garage to the side so in total it would
be about 183 square meters
I may have missed a trick here but was
there a house on this site
stood the site as shown here is
currently garden land associated with
Pinehurst so there is no dwelling on
this part of the site okay I just asked
a particular question on the because
obviously it is quite a significant
building within this plot would it be
appropriate to remove permitted
development rights on this property if
we if permission was granted officers
didn't consider that permitted
development rights were required to be
removed from this property in terms of
either the impacts on neighbors or in
terms of the impacts on character
obviously it's something that we could
look to condition if members wish to
clarification is the three bedrooms and
lose the three lose they don't know
blues outside these days if the parish
council said there were three bedrooms
and three lose I'm just looked at me the
other ways to but this is bedroom one
which does have an ensuite bathroom this
is bedroom two as shown and this is
bedroom three or a study bedroom one is
the only one with an ensuite bathroom
there is a separate bathroom shown here
as well okay members only no further
questions clarification right open to
debate Council Ritter's first and then
category Thank You chairman based on the
fact that at outline stage we accepted
the positioning and the size as it was
presented then I don't think you should
come as a surprise that it is how it
looks now and on that basis I'm entirely
happy with the
officers recommendation and I propose
that we grant on that particular point
do you feel that permitted development
rights should be removed or not we
didn't feel it appropriate to do it at
the outline stage I don't see why we
should now okay I have any other open
for debate
council carry mm-hmm yeah I just think I
think the parish council point that
outline is outline and yes there was an
indicative sighting but that's
indicative and their points about it
being too large and setback are
completely valid no matter what came
forward as an indicative plan this is
the time we decide with reasons what's
acceptable to actually be built the
parish council have decided that what's
before us now which is what it's
important not then isn't acceptable for
the reason it's set back and the reason
it's too large I personally disagree
with that but that they're valid
arguments to bring forward at this stage
I think because it's a local needs
dwelling there's another point there
raised by the parish council that it's
too big and and it's not suitable for
the type of need it's required for the
the occupant or the the hopeful occupant
say well it it could be a small family
and I'm very much in favor of that but I
think a small family or a downsizing is
appropriate but a much bigger house than
what is potentially a three-bedroom
houses is maybe not appropriate and if
the parish council say it's not
appropriate now then an even bigger
house would certainly not be appropriate
in the parish councils view for local
needs so in my view we should take off
those permitted development rights that
could extend the house they can come
back and ask for planning permission and
give reasons why but it's
just be loud I feel you've got a house
now which is more than big enough for
the needs of the present owners and
probably big enough and for future needs
and remember it's local needs and
affordability is important and the
bigger the house the more it costs so I
would second it if you put the PD rights
on cattle Thank You chairman I
completely agree with councillor courage
I do take the point of the Parish
Council it might be a wee bit big we're
looking at nine square metres and I'm
totally convinced that the need for that
potential third bedroom is very
important in terms of special needs
because carers do have to stay over
whether that's a family member or but a
full-time carer so I've got no problem
with that
potential third bedroom I do completely
agree with councillor carriage I'd be
happy to support this and I would like
to see permitted railroad rights
restricted can you confirm this is in
Greenbelt given that it's in Greenbelt
the properties affords additional
protection anyway if any changes are so
any increase in size of the property
itself are proposed they would be will
require planning permission because of
that so right if I misunderstood them in
terms of permitted development lights do
you mean or just general and any form of
extension to it
normal permitted development rights
would still apply even though it is in
Greenville okay no look I don't feel
there is a need to remove the PD rights
but I understand your argument and I'm
willing to accept it thank you we have a
proposer with the the addition of
removal of PD rights cancer carriage
you're happy to second that 100k right
members the vote before you is to grant
a plan commission for 17/2 six three oh
sorry I'm including the removal of
of PD rights as a condition all those in
favor
that's unanimous Jenna this can be
therefore resolved the grand plan
permission 470 such go to six for your M
thank you right our next item on the
agenda is 1702 76 5 slash ball which is
postures Kroft Paul head and kindest
before I go into that one do we have the
presentation sorry just there he goes
right we're now going to go to 1702 7 6
5 - full pastors Croft pull headline and
they're still trying to find it I do
apologize what would this do this one
first and then we'll take it from me
okay then over to shalva thank you Thank
You chairman
the site is indicated on the map by the
black circle the application site is
located within the open countryside on
Poole head Lane the site is part of the
curtilage of pastures Croft a tea story
dwelling the site is approximately 170
meters out of the settlement with the
nearest settlement being wood and which
can be seen here this slide shows the
applications I edged in red the site
would continue to be accessed from pool
head lane which sits directly to the
northeast of the site the site is
currently garden land associated with
pastures Croft which is a two storey
building seemed to rally to the
northwest the site benefits from tree
preservation orders which can be seen
indicated by the green dotted lines and
green circles open fields abut the site
to the south and east across the highway
to the north our additional open fields
the site is also within the mess West
Midlands Greenbelt as well as the art
and special landscape area this is an
application for full planning permission
for a local needs bungalow along with
improvements to the existing field
access this plan shows the proposed
siting of the new Lake who needs
bungalow as well as the access onto pool
head Lane this would be improved a new
gate erected a driveway with turning
area would also be provided within the
site the bungalow would be sited
approximately nine and a half metres
back from the highway edge at this point
garden land would be provided to the
side and rear of the bungalow the
location of the trees on the site is
marked by blue circles with their red
dotted ripped action areas this slide
shows the proposed floor plan the bone
layer would be broadly al shapes and
would measure sixth approximately
seventeen point five meters in width
thirteen meters in length and five point
three meters in Heights it would be hit
brief and would benefit from three
bedrooms and an integral garage this
slide shows the proposed front elevation
at the top of the screen and the
proposed eastern side elevation on the
bottom the proposed hip reef and
fenestration can be seen this side
elevation would face towards the ash
tree which benefits
TPI this slide shows the proposed rear
elevation again on top of the screen
with proposed western elevation on the
bottom there are no windows proposed
along this side of elevation this slide
shows the frontage of the site facing
towards the North West pastures Croft
the existing dwelling can be seen in the
background the hedge along the frontage
of the site would be removed to enable
the development to proceed and to allow
the visibility's Bay to be achieved the
hedge on the right-hand side screens the
open fields from the highway this photo
is looking southeast along Poole head
lane showing the frontage of the site
with the trees and open fields beyond
the access is again visible where the
wooden gate can be seen this photo is
taken just inside the site facing north
west towards Pine sorry towards their
pastures Croft the dwelling and
associated garage can be seen on the
right hand side this photo is again
taken from the frontage of the site
facing towards the rear boundary the
trees which are visible along the rear
boundary are those which benefit from a
blanket tree preservation order this
photo is taken just within the site
facing southeast towards the ash tree
which is also subject to a TPI
this photo is taken close to the rear
and side branches of the site facing
north you can see the existing hedge
which is to be removed as well as the
access which is marked by the gate just
to clarify there are no updates officer
recommendation is to refuse the
application for full planning permission
for the reasons which can be found on
page 94 of the agenda first speakers are
Nikki flora and mr. Colin cleaver
thank you have three minutes in your own
time good evening I am the agent for the
application acting on behalf of the
applicants up beside me the presented
application is very similar to the
previously refused application from July
2016 however there were some key
elements including highways that have
now been addressed as we have heard the
two remaining reasons for refusal our
one site is not considered to be within
or adjacent to a settlement and has not
been demonstrated to be a community led
local needs dwelling to the scheme
represents inappropriate development
with the green belt and no very special
circumstances exists to outweigh the
harm identified I intend to provide a
brief overview in the time bread with
the key points that we firmly believe
constitutes application being very
special circumstances the application is
for a modest low-profile bungalow
carefully planned not to intrude into
the landscape where the planning officer
has stated that the building would not
result in harm to the character and
appearance of the area the new property
is solely for the applicants own use for
the immediate future and they're keen to
hollow that there was no commercial
intent whatsoever the new dwelling is
sited on previously developed land that
housed a number of livestock farm
outbuildings as such in real terms of
proposal is seen as having very little
impact on the openness of the Greenbelt
furthermore in the context of the
highways England proposals to install
smart motorway countries in this area a
single-story dwelling on previously
developed land and surely be of minimal
impacts to the Greenbelt within the
offices report for the consented
application for two new dwellings in
February 2017 at the longest and
property on Paul head Lane the planning
officer stated that the site was located
within a clearly defined ribbon of
development and was deemed to be within
the village confines given the plasters
cross site is less than 200 metres from
that property with further properties
between the two it must be surely be
considered to be the edge of the village
contrary to the first reason for refusal
the lake's railway station is in fact a
ten to fifteen minute walk from the site
on smoky and small virtually
traffic-free lanes and a flexi bus
services in operation in normal areas
like tan worth the perception of
sustainability is necessarily different
from that in suburban locations where
residents will rely on the use of
car although the proposed bungalows for
the applicants immediate use they have
made the decision to offer it as a local
needs dwelling having lived in the
village for over 40 years they are well
aware of the need for this type of
dwelling to meet the needs of the
community the parish councils objection
to the current proposal is inconsistent
with the extremely strong level support
they gave previously for such a dwelling
in the recent appeal decision it was
highlighted what requirements are
broadly needed to be met for
consideration as a local needs scheme in
line with the council's SPD such as
needs to be small in scale within or
adjacent to the village a scheme which
provides for market housing with a local
connection community led to led which
can be evidenced by a recent parish
housing needs survey clearly the
application meets these needs and
reinforced by the parish councils 2016
housing needs survey which indicated
that nearly 20% of residents would
prefer a bungalow there are clearly
medical and health concerns there
proactively driven the need for both
applications the applicants have made
the best of the existing property for
the past 18 months but now hit the point
where it has fallen well below the
quality provision that could be provided
by a new-build single-story dwelling the
planning system is there to support as
well as regulate a clear aim of the MP
MP FF that planning must be a creative
exercise in finding ways to enhance and
improve the places in which we live our
lives I can see no better reasons for
the very special circumstances than
those presented before you I would
therefore ask the committee to consider
the application favourable thank you
thank you yeah thanks mr. clerk perhaps
you could just expand upon your comment
that there was some previous development
on this side good unit-buying me please
yes of course and the as you can see the
existing pastures croft property on the
top left-hand corner the site was the
original farm building left main
farmhouse and and the existing access
which obviously as I stated as it's got
no highways objection in its
improvements that are being proposed and
was the access onto the farm
outbuildings which was the Romany
livestock and when were those buildings
demolish because it looks very sort of
gardeny to me yeah absolutely
I need to clarify the exact dates but we
believe it was about 30 years ago
caravans
oK we've had three rip users on this
site you intimated the parish council
supported the last one it's absolutely
correct
the application was refused in 2016 was
initially deferred after the first
committee on both the committees the
parish council spoke in support of the
identical footprint identical position
and the actual proposal itself and the
only difference being that this time it
was a decision by the applicant that
he'd like to offer it as a local needs
dwelling and I think potentially there
was some confusion by the parish council
as to what that actually meant okay
thank you very much thank you right
catechism
Thank You chairman members and officers
this is interesting actually because the
application you considered earlier
mirrors what is occurring now when that
came up it was recommended for refusal
but it was agreed because of special
needs circumstances and it's all the rod
actually that in the application which
was previously there you know the
comments the application site is in open
countryside but an outline approval for
local needs Bhangra was approved in 2016
I think also which relates to this is
the comment on the previous one that if
development would be acceptable when
viewed from the street to the front as
well as open countryside it's in the
open countryside so the absent the
little on one is and depends what mean
by open countryside I'd like to cover
that earlier but there seems to be quite
a contradiction what's happening there
and what is in this report here however
at a recent appeal an inspector did
outline in detail what the local needs
scheming requires and some of the points
which he mentions needs to be small in
scale which obviously a bungalow is and
this one happens to be within or
adjacent to the village oblique
settlement having regard to the site's
physical and functional relationship
adjacent to the village or settlement
not part of it it's there as in which
provides for either affordable or market
housing with a local connection we've
got a forty year local connection here
the community lead scheme which finishes
of all recent parish housing needs
survey which has been concluded and
which the agent tells you on growth of
this nature have been identified in the
WRC see housing needs survey twenty
eight in total or attentive
there it goes on actually contributes to
the overall housing requirements were
less that is very much the case and the
issue earlier of course was by Highway
Authority who objected that is now being
removed and my memory tells me that that
was the only issue which inhibited
members I believe from reversing the
recommendation to refused to what if
grant the location is pretty close it's
not too bad it's about four fifths of a
mile from one railway station and
slightly more from another I don't have
it in meters because my car doesn't
measure that sort of distance it is only
in my four fifths and that is to the
legs and a similar but not a great deal
more to would end there also within it
are is the access to facilities
including a retail development which
sells a whole variety of consumer goods
as well as household needs there is also
just about opposite small Lane where
development is and also Fowler's cheese
factory you may have heard as far as
cheese which is very famous on report
there so it's not as if it were in open
countryside you're interfering with
let's say a constable landscape there
are buildings about in fact you can
actually see from pastures Croft an
adjacent house in the next field that
very further up pool head leg close to
is also a scaffolding builders yard it's
quite an extensive thing all readers of
self scaffolding you should see it it's
quite amazing then opposite there
there's Biddle's Hill which has ten
houses there it's not by any stretch of
the imagination an isolated building in
the open
beside it is as you agreed previously
for the previous application when it
first came yeah you know appropriate for
the setting also of course in another
appeal which i think is very important
in dealing with these things
the inspector do 30 seconds please yeah
the benefits set out in the NPV F
manifestly outweigh the minor are
identified that is the minor harm to
anything which may be there and in this
instance I believe this is very much
established as a local housing needs
requirement you've agreed that in the
past chairman in little on I don't see
the contrast here apart from the fact
that this site is much closer to
amenities and the built form that is the
embankment thing in the countryside how
close is it to build form on this one is
I hope members will see the rationale of
that and support the applicant thank you
very much councillor thank you members
are any questions you'd like to write no
thank you very much cancer right
technical questions Catholic is another
carriage I don't see an assessment of
special circumstances within your report
were only presented to you during their
process planning process but I've I
missed them in your report the very
special circumstances have been weighed
up within the conclusion section of the
report which is on page is 92 and 93
okay and in relation to the previous
application we've heard from a couple of
people that the local needs position
weighed heavily on that decision can you
explain to me the difference between the
local needs on that and the local needs
in this instance please say the
difference between the local needs
dwelling Inlet alone and their dwelling
today it was a previous application
there was a tie on that one for local
needs and a gift to the parish council
how is this one different the previous
application on this site was for a
neighbor market
not on their site the various
application tonight
the pine hasn't sorry yes say their
previous application the Pinehurst
application was assessed in terms of the
local need that there had been a local
need identified pilots by the parish for
bungalows in that location whereas in
this application there is no um parish
plan which requires any bungalows of
this type in the location and then
neighborhood development plan is at an
early stage are though there has been a
housing needs survey completed in 2016
this does only carry limited weight at
this stage can security wait the housing
needs urgent survey did say what we've
been told that bungalows were desired
after the respondents 18 percent did say
that they would prefer a bungalow in the
housing needs survey and have you got
any shots of that road I remember I
haven't visited since the last time can
you show us how close it is in that yeah
cuz I'm just assessing is this next to
the settlement or not so I think that's
what it for me that's what it hinges on
so this is a site indicated by the black
circle the closest settlement which is a
would end is it's a local service
village yeah so can you
where does would end because there's a
road that goes from would end which is
built up on either side I believe and
then presumably on one side for bit so
where does it where does that settlement
edge it hasn't got the settlement
boundary but does it have a settlement
boundary in our SPD which is coming here
and what's the proposed settlement
boundary would end this would be outside
physical confines or the built-up area
boundary for the settlement in terms of
the closest part of the settlement would
end is
believe it the hundred prods mate 180
meters away from the site itself I will
just check that Li yes 170 meters
outside of the settlement and and when
when you say outside of the settlement
where does that definition come from
where is that definition that's taken in
terms of the closest dwelling which is
considered to be within the settlement
so that's a long pool headline yes so
who makes that in you know some places
have a line Biddeford has a line around
it this is the settlement this is the
settlement boundary and that's what
we're going towards in our SPD but we
haven't got there yet
so in this case is that an officer
judgment of where would end ends or is
this something else yes that's an
officer measurement of the distance from
the site to the closest dwelling which
is on Paul headline in in the settlement
itself so there's nothing between that
that last one on Paul headline and this
dwelling or other other dwellings in
between this dwelling and what you
consider to be the the end of wouldn't
because this is the crux of it so
there's no other dwellings that I'm
aware of within that section between
would end itself and their site is of
counterbalance
the sorry the closest train stations
actually sites that would end and it's
approximately 1.3 kilometer walked there
Castle Dean can we assume that the
motorway that originally that was a farm
house and farm buildings was it the
motorway that affected it and has now
made it unviable and therefore the farm
can no longer work and their buildings
were I presume taken down is that right
I can't really come into that that
hasn't form part of the assessment of
this application Thank You chair um just
if you wouldn't mind could you go back
to the the site plan as proposed because
I just wanted to query something about
the road access I can't really see but
is that a gated access yes a replacement
gate is proposed at the front of the
site so if you wanted to get in there
and the gate was closed you still have
to park the car on the road get out open
the gate
get him yes if we were minded to to
accept this then as a supplementary
question would it be possible to put a
condition that the gate was contained
within the site so at least one vehicle
could park off the road to gain access
to the to the premises the gates is is
sited further into the site at this
location oh it's there okay okay and it
is one of their conditions suggested by
highways as well okay fine I'm sorry I
should have read that my apologies
okay any other questions right I shall
open it up
[Music]
Thank You chairman um
the key for me and this is is this the
fact that it's it within the in the
green belt in order for us to overcome
harm to the green belt there has to be
special so it either has to fit into one
of the exceptions which this doesn't or
very special circumstances have to be
presented in my opinion very special
circumstances haven't been presented in
this instance certainly nothing that
would outweigh the harm that some that
this would cause the price council have
trying to find it
I think they've said that they don't
identify this as a local need there is a
personal need but a local need that
cannot therefore be used as a special
circumstance and is therefore very
different from the application we heard
just a moment ago I also think passion
has made a very valid point that if we
were looking at something that was a
replacement dwelling for the dwellings
that are on-site we may be more inclined
to accept this but that's not what we're
looking at we're looking at an
additional one it requires special
circumstances we do not have them and
therefore we should be refusing on that
basis so I'm entirely happy again with
the officers recommendation and I
propose that we refuse in line with that
with her recommendation thank you I mean
I I do agree with this I mean there are
a number things because sustainability
is an interesting one it is different to
rural there isn't I fully accept that
and people do temping much more reliable
resilient shall we say in there is
however we're talking distances
significant distances walking 15 minutes
or so down what is it an omelette
country lane and it is a long it's a 50
mile an hour limit down there I think it
was before if I remember rightly so
again I don't think that's a very very
years sustainable way of working you
gotta drive it's inevitable agree with
you the local needs hasn't been
identified satisfactorily it's not in
the built up area boundary I think the
officer
explain that one so I I am with you on
that particular point and I'm willing to
second that as well castle bondsman I
think this distance from the railway
station or any facilities in my eyes
sustainability is 800 yards or meters
whatever it might be and it's in the
Greenbelt and I don't disagree with the
officers recommendation I would second
it as well
thank you chair I mean this has been
before us before and and I bid against
it on principle in the past
I am minded however to note that
Lawrence auroral have done a survey and
identified a need for a number of
bungalows within this area and and to my
mind well if there is a demand where are
you going to build them um the whole of
the error is washed over by Greenbelt
there is no significant built-up area
boundary that's going to accommodate
this amount of houses so from that point
of view I wonder whether we could argue
that this is an exception and you could
again say is this easy to sustainable
location well again we're from a very
rural area you have to take a view on
sustainability
I understand obviously that the existing
house and whatever it is blighted
because of the proximity to the the
Gypsy encampment you know we have got
precedent where we've done this before
and obviously the ward councillors made
reference to do little on I am more than
knighted to actually go against the
officers recommendation here there is a
special there is an exception in my view
I don't think this is a big building I
would certainly like to see the old
building torn down
but and that's that's not up for debate
we're just looking at this chairman Matz
that's just where I am thank you
right casa building I will go along with
councillor look I think there is a
special circumstances there and I'm
quite happy to follow what he is just
proposed or stated thank you but we do
have a proposal on the second and the
the vote therefore members before you is
to refuse planning permission for 17s -
OH - seven six five - four all those in
favor against - against this committee
therefore resolves to refuse flames
motion 1702 seven six five - cool thank
you
we're going to carry on for the moment
with the agenda we'll go back to the
item 17 5 0 to 9 1 1/4
I do apologize we trying to get onto the
onto the system and when we've got it
we'll have to shut down to get it on and
I think we'd better do our first one are
the ones first
yeah I think we'll just have a fire main
break
members we will have to vote in a minute
to carry on as well what's under we have
to
able to go back to the previous item
which is 17 - OH - nine more months a
full James is presenting and I do
apologize to the IT issues and but
counsel Richard came to the rescue
thank you
Thank You chair yeah sorry for the least
Lloyds IT hitch there and that will
progress with the application so the
applications for the conversion of an
agricultural barn to three holiday homes
and associated developments the
application site is located as you can
see here by the black dots just to the
north of the village of dossing t'en
there is a public footpath that runs
there to the north of the site as well
and it's in the open countryside
location so this is just an aerial view
of the of the site and the red line
there just around the existing barn this
is the application site as existing and
I've got a comparative slide show as
proposed your notes here that the
existing access in this position here is
being closed often for a reinstated
hedge and new access has open up here
into onto the door Tintin Lane
so some comparative elevations because
The Associated works do do require some
installation of some fenestration
details there some windows and roof
lights and that's from the side
elevation view and these are the
existing floor plans and the proposed so
just showing the bedroom so the three
independent units one one will be one
bed and the other two will be too bad
this is the current photo of the barn
just taken from within the site and this
is from the the highway Dawson turn lane
and then this is where the access gate
will be closed up and a hedge reinstated
in that position thank you
the record sorry the recommendation is
to grant to subject the conditions
outlined in the officers report thank
you thank you right we don't have anyone
from the parish and councillor Barnes
has now departed Andrew will now speak
thank you Andrew again apologies for the
delay
Thank You chairman sings off kymaro's
will speak sapphire barn is a wooden
barn constructed in 2004 as part of the
Dawson's and Farms estate owned by the
late Felix Dennis and is now managed by
the charity heart of England forest
LaVon has become surplus to requirements
so it is proposed change its use to
three holiday homes this will give more
income to the charity and holidaymakers
can walk the new woodlands and network
of permissive footpaths opened up by the
charity in providing the visibility
splay the shorter roadside hedge will be
removed and a new hedge planted further
back behind display with further
planting of orchard trees and this is in
addition to the hundreds of thousands of
trees already planted by the charity the
roadside trees are located behind the
proposed visibility splay and so will be
retained there for the proposed holiday
holiday homes have a safe means of
access from the public highway with a
minimal impact on the character of the
area another issue is parking there is
an attractive Burak apron in front of
the barn that will be retained as a car
park for the holiday homes the Parish
Council is concerned that eight standard
sized parking spaces is too many for
three holiday homes however I would
rather not break up the attractive brick
pavers and reduce the carpark
there is no harm in having spare hardest
hard standing for guests maintenance
vehicles pot plants etc furthermore
large cast tend to take up to standard
parking spaces with regards to
residential immunity the one side window
facing sapphire house which is to the
right on those photographs will be
fitted with obscure glass there is one
proposed rear first-floor window the
newest house to the rear is located 55
meters away and behind mature trees
and 55 meters is way beyond the
councilors recommended minimum standards
of 21 meters between face and
first-floor windows so in conclusion
there are many planning policies that
support the principle of rural tourism
and visitor accommodation I ask you to
support the charity and the officer
recommendation and grant planning
permission thank you thanks
it's interesting to see oversupply of
parking it's the first time I think I've
ever seen that as an application but
thank you very much indeed for that
particular one I was going to say no I
think that is it and you yeah any other
questions okay thank you very much you
need under um right technical questions
James
any questions there I must admit it no
okay go to debate council Richards
slightly disappointed the parish council
haven't sent up to support their
objection I understand councillor bonds
removed his before he left on that basis
I see no reason why we would object so I
proposed we granted in line with the
recommendation thank you very much I
must admit sometimes these when they
come to a converter bar that's only a
few years old I have a twitchy feeling
that it was done deliberately in this
particular case it was 2004 I don't
believe that was the case in this
particular instance and on I'm happy to
go along with with that as well
councillor carry no yeah okay second so
the vote before you is to grant Planning
Commission for 7502 nine more months
asphalt
all those in favor this committee
therefore resolves to grant line closure
for 17/8 nine more months watch for was
it worth waiting for hundred thank you
thanks so much indeed bye-bye right next
item on the agenda is 17 - oh one oh
eight Oh Scott's fault
oh it's and Paul had lain in town with
an ardent Andrew until easily
surely application is to erect a triple
garage adjacent to this property on the
west side of Paul head Lane in this
instance it's been recognized that the
proposal is within that that ribbon of
development of would end and that
forming part of the would end settlement
we discussed earlier so here's the
here's the the plot of land and its
dwelling within that ribbon development
an aerial photograph and I've marked
clear water on the south side there
that's the neighboring property where
some concern has been raised about loss
of amenity and over Barents from from
the scheme this is the existing access
into the site and you just see the the
dwelling on the right-hand side there
and that's a better view of it and
there's another view of it and the
triple garage would be sited in this
position here where existing hard
standing is and that's on just just to
the rear of the hard standing looking
back out towards the road through
through the gates
this again is clear water and you can
just see the dwelling host dwelling
application dwelling just peeping
through on that that shot and the garage
would be sited behind that conifer tree
on either side of the boundary obviously
he exists indwelling the sight for the
garage and here we have the garage
proposal itself the application also
includes economy canopy to the rear of
the dwelling and also the proposal
includes the blocking up of the existing
garage opening to form a gymnasium
within it was the elevation of the house
with the gouge just a left set part part
of the garage and just marked on the
outline
the garage to get members an idea of its
scale adjacent to the undeveloped early
elevation of the house this is the
garage itself three Bay's with ancillary
living accommodation above just just to
cover off the the canopy at the rear so
that that relates to this part here
remembers the application is to approve
Thank You chair thank you
I know that we don't have the Parish
Council who brought this to a committee
speaking our first speaker is Nick again
good evening again as with the previous
application I'm the agent for the
application acting on behalf the
applicants mr. and mrs. McLean and given
the officers recommendation for the
granting of this application
I intend to purely address the two
objections from the protocol and from
one of the neighboring properties and as
you have heard from the Pauline officers
presentation and and contained within
the agenda pack the application posters
have been carefully considered and to
designed to ensure that the appropriate
setting and to ensure that the new
carriage block is subservient to the
main house which was constructed in 2006
and occupied by the applicants in 2008
and the parish council have objected on
the basis of the proposals constitute
over development of the site and will
have an adverse impact on the openness
of the Greenbelt as has been seen from
the officers presentation and the
application site is of substantial area
of some 1 Acre the designs have been I
stopped back from that one and the
designs have been prepared in the belief
that they are appropriate development
with no harm to the visual appearance
and openness of the Greenbelt which has
been concurred by the planning officer
in their recommendation for approval of
the proposed additional site volume of
approximately 30% only around 10%
equates to habitable space in the form
of the accommodation over the garage as
highlighted by the office of the
proposals would not be considered
disproportionate in the context of
Greenbelt policy the proposed rear
canopy is well confined within the width
of the rear elevation and projects us in
a meter from the existing rear balcony
projections the upper floors and is
therefore considered to have a minimal
visual impact alongside the existing
rear elevation the proposed garage with
accommodation over has been carefully
positioned to minimize any impact on the
adjoining neighbors by lying to metres
from the boundary to the rear and some
2.9 meters from the boundary to the
front of the proposed garage the overall
height of the pros garage has been set
to ensure it remains considerably lower
than
main house and exciting to the side of
the neighbors non habitable carriage
which contains no side windows is
considered to negate any impact on their
property unfortunately despite repeated
attempts by the applicants to engage
with the concerned neighbor throughout
the extended determination period it
appears most likely that their objection
and to this application is stem more out
of a historic frustration for the
consented proposals for the existing
dwelling that lie back in 2005 overall
overall wise we fully respect the parish
councils entitlement to objective
proposals we do not believe the reasons
for their objection apply to the
presented application which has clearly
outlined in the officers reports comply
with local and national planning policy
as such we would ask the committee to
consider this application favorably and
grant consent thank you any questions
thank you right the parish councils
objection of course they you know over
development of the site I think it's
over a naked quite a statement actually
but the other issue is on page 101 the
third paragraph
takes care of any overshadowing or
overlooking and I think with those two
assurances that it's not over the
development the neighbor fortunately
it's not adversely affected I'd urge the
committee to support the officers
recommendation promptly thank you that
is a record
thank you very much cancer and technical
questions no debate council Richards
simply in Councilwoman
I think the assessment is absolutely
spot-on I propose to be granting my
lover's recommendation very succinctly
councillor ikenson
I are quite happy to second this and I
just we'd like to point out to members
that there are very similar applications
like this with subservient garages to
large houses certainly one within my
ward where the officers have recommended
refusal and this parrot and this members
have gone along with the office of
Reclamation I can't see any difference
between this but I'm happy to accept it
thank you the vote members before you
okay any comment was that there was a
window on the side of the building that
was the reason why we refused it last
time right thank you the vote before you
is to grant planning permission was 1701
Oh a toast us for all those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resolves to grant plan from 1700 108 Oh
special thank you
the final item on the agenda is 17/2
9 9 OS for the firs broad Lane
10 within a husband and Anthony is again
presenting
Cheerilee application is is to remove an
existing dwelling from a within a ribbon
of development again in would end and to
replace that dwelling with two dwellings
within the gap that will be formed so
here we have here we have the site and
the site edged read and see the dwelling
sitting there between existing dwellings
aerial photograph so we're moving on to
the proposal here and I've included a
contextual image which gives members an
idea of how the new dwellings will fit
within that context so the new dwellings
have been highlighted in blue and they
sit over the existing dwelling to be
removed and here's a clearer shot of how
the disposition of the dwelling is on
site in relation to the neighboring
properties and members will note that
well the road runs along the bottom here
and the cops of trees which are fall
within the residential curtilage will be
retained and the access which presently
swoops round here in and out onto the
road that will now be subdivided so that
one end of it will serve plot one and
the other end will serve plot two
members will also see that there are two
detached garage one in front of each
dwelling one for each dwelling these are
the elevations of the proposal plot one
plot ones floor plans so 2/3 the ground
first and second floors of the second
floor occupying the roof void in each
case
lots of elevations artist impression
from the front and just just to show
members of the building that would be
removed rather a handsome building but
say it's not protected by listing or any
other protection Andrea Gordon's her
rear view of the house
there's the some images of the existing
access and the cops the trees I referred
to and them as this is in the Greenbelt
and the policy that has been applied is
the the infilling of a existing built-up
frontage which which is a an exception
in Greenbelt policy and that's the
policy that officers have applied and
you chair the recommendation is to a to
approve thank you thank you
our first speaker is large or color the
agent thank you your perseverance three
minutes in your own time good evening
chairman and members thank you for
allowing me to speak on Nigel Kahlo from
energy AC design limited the agent and
principal designer on the project
speaking in support of a client's
application the site is set within the
recognized village envelope of Tam
within Arden and follows detailed pre
and post application consultations with
officers the proposal set out before you
incorporates various amendments to the
original design which have fully taken
account of comments from your offices to
reduce the scale and mass of the
proposed buildings our clients have been
proactive in duly modifying the scheme
to be appropriate within the village
environments and the wider Greenbelt
this application is a bespoke design
suited to the context and setting and
the constraints of the site all of which
have fully inform the scheme adjustments
were made to ensure that
and design criteria have been met to
achieve development as satisfies both
local and national planning guidance
your planning offices are fully
contented with the quality of the scheme
and that it satisfies your adopted
policy and supplementary design
requirements the proposal provides a
well-balanced high quality cohesive
scheme it does not represent over
development of the site and should be
considered to be wholly appropriate in
this setting the highways accesses are
already established vehicles will
continue to be able to enter and leave
the site in a forward gear maintaining
current safety standards within this
world resolve robust and safe design
parking and turning provisions for
residents on the site are clearly laid
out in an appropriate manner the new
dwelling sits on large plots set well
back from the road frontage where the
development will have a secluded quality
behind newly enhanced landscaping
creating a positive impacts overall
there's an eclectic mix of property
types locally this diverse mix
contributes towards the local areas
general character with the careful use
of facing materials for the two
dwellings with varied elevation designs
the development will also contribute to
equally to that local area character
Julie enhancing the setting the proposal
offers no significant harm or impact in
terms of overlooking or overshadowing to
neighbors but will provide a secured by
design enhancement and improved
surveillance around we have reviewed the
various objections and firmly believe
that there are no material planning
considerations arising from the matters
raised by objectives that would provide
appropriate reasons to refuse this
scheme in conclusion we have read your
office's reports and concur fully with
its recommendations the scheme provides
appropriate replacement and infill
development which will enhance the
visual quality of the street scene
overall the bespoke design is both
innovative and wholly appropriate and in
accord with your adopted policies we do
consideration to all of the matters
we've mentioned here today and with
respect to your office's detailed report
we respectfully request that the
application be approved at the seedings
meeting thank you thank you very much
indeed that was very quick answer can we
go back to the original layout or site
planning
that blue area at the back there what it
is that part of the site all these are
going to be divided up or what is going
to happen to it a chair I think that is
to be remain in the ownership of plot1
but there is the potential for it to be
subdivided at a later date
it doesn't form parts of the application
currently thank you mrs. garden it says
the search on the plot it says retained
changes garden land yeah it is here okay
any other questions thank you very much
cancer are consumed
Thank You chairman members and officers
this is infill actually the officer does
describe it on page one more note
towards the top the purpose of it which
contradicts what the Parish Council
raised in their objection and we have
seen a number in the parish of this
nature just around the or further down
Broad Lane actually there was a very
similar case brought in a few months ago
and that went through and it's a good
way to absorb Without Really interfering
with the value of the Greenbelt these
very very large pots because they're
still left with a fair bit of immunity
area this certainly will achieve that
without any doubt as indeed has happened
on pool headland chairmen where one unit
one house had in filling on either side
so they had two units there which
matches very well as surrounding and
it's very close to pastras Croft that
one and pool headland
I hope members will endorse the officers
recommendation and quickly agree the
application Thank You councillor right
technical questions I just one I I can
understand the confusion about infill
but just for clarification please why is
this in not in it is infill as opposed
to looking on down yes so if there's a
house in a more isolated position that
wasn't in the settlement and the
proposal was to demolish and replaced
with two dwellings and I would be
clearly in breach of Greenbelt policy
because it doesn't benefit from that
exception and equally we have not
applied at the policy of demolition in
this case if let me just rewind slightly
if an application came in to demolish a
house in a more isolated location in the
Greenbelt then it would be at this
restriction on that on that house to not
exceed significant significantly the
size of the original dwelling that only
applies
in a situation where it's not infill but
this is infill therefore that policy
doesn't apply thank you
right debate council couch yeah it's a
shame again we didn't see the council
because I can all the all the ones here
we've had three or four today where the
parish council didn't turn up for and
and if they did you know we they can
argue their case they can give us they
can give us inside I can't I can't I
can't really act on a few lines in here
in the past we came up with an idea to
just to just go to office officer
recommendation if the parish of the ward
member who'd objected didn't turn up I
don't know what happened to that idea
but I'd like to back it in the absence
of that I'd say we go straight to grant
and I go without supporting it so the
proposal counselor mr. kazlaw it's our
second ever to see everything that
counselor carriages just said if these
applications have been forced hereby
pronounce assemble to turn up it's
common decency to support your objection
in this instance and we've had to
assemble and they haven't shown up but
for their benefit and they haven't shown
up so I find that enormous ly
frustrating and but I will second your I
just like to say that I thought the
design of the buildings and the way that
they're different is absolutely it's a
spectacular really pleased to see that
but one of the best designs we've seen
all year it is a good design alright so
members the vote before you is to grant
Planning Commission for 17 / 9 9 Oh such
for all those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resolved to grant claims of his 17 sighs
Oh 299 Oh social and that's the last
item on the agenda I have many other
business III actually I fully support
what kind of encourages said and I'd
like you as our Chairman to go to our
lawyer speak about policy and find out
whether we can or can't go straight to
offers a recommendation if someone is
forced this
committee and not Bullock to turn up
okay didn't waste well raise it I will
write it I would to talk to Ross about
that just a few minutes ago but yes we
it raise it is something thank you good
night all